Yeah,
that's a good fucking book.
Dude.
Did a great job with this thing.
Oh thanks man.
It was a lot of work,
I would imagine.
I don't know.
How the hell are you have the time.
Where do you see volume two?
We live.
So tell me how the fuck do you have the time to do this?
I'm looking at this book,
the complete guide to hunting,
butchering and cooking wild game.
Steve Ronell's here,
ladies and Gentlemen,
Ladies and gentlemen,
Steven Noah put on my fucking media.
Oh,
I like that.
Like that.
I was 40.
How do you have the time to do this book?
You know?
Well,
I got into doing the book.
Um,
that was a great opening to the show by the way.
Thank you very much.
When I started doing that book,
I thought I'd take eight months,
man.
Ah,
we just got on this idea that,
you know,
I wanted to do as,
I wanted to do a book about a field care and butchering and stuff,
but then some of the studies should be bigger.
It should be like the complete guide or we started using the word complete and
what I keep saying now is how I should add it for long time.
I really regretted including the word complete in the proposal because as we sat
down
initially I would sit down with with Dodi who you know,
well Dan Dodi and we would just start mapping out,
okay
we had like a board,
you know,
and sticky notes and we just start mapping out like what were complete look
like.
And then it grew and grew and already,
you know,
he was working on the show and moved on to some other things.
It's still was involved and other guys came in and Yannis,
you know,
we start working on it and just trying to manage the idea and pretty soon,
I mean a lot of people worked on that book.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean I was in there on the writing process and it turned into several,
it took several years to do them.
Then when I took it to my publisher,
she had me in its published by Spiegel and Grau at random house and she had me
into the office and we had turned it in.
It was going to be 700 and some pages long.
And she said like,
it's just,
books aren't like,
you just don't really,
you know,
you got to understand like that's a big book.
Yeah.
You don't really do illustrated books that big.
Um,
so we were going to hack a bunch out but then we kind of hit on this idea just
to polish it and two things as volume one and volume two.
But it wasn't just as simple as splitting it down the middle.
So,
uh,
it took probably another,
I don't know,
almost a year maybe to,
to turn it into volume one big game,
volume two small game.
That's awesome.
Big Effort,
man.
I know how much you work and how much you travel and how many hunts you go on.
And I don't just know how the fuck you did it.
I've ever been down.
We were down in,
uh,
I was down in a fan with my family,
just vacation in Baja and I remember sitting there and we were fishing and stuff
and we had two babies with us.
And I'm sitting there trying to like work on that book.
I just worked on all the time.
But,
but the thing is I don't want it,
like I did a lot of work on it,
but everybody,
a lot of the guys,
you know,
worked on it a ton too,
like all that recipe stuff.
Um,
you know,
Dodie like we did a big shoot,
dirty kind of organizes she with some other folks and like we organized a week
of just cooking and photographing.
But the other thing is a lot of this stuff in there too,
the images,
you'd kind of look at the image,
you'd be like,
well how would you go and get all these images?
You'd never be able to justify getting those images to make a book.
But we had,
uh,
access to so many hours of hunting footage of all this stuff.
So we're able to do something called screen grabs.
So in there is a lot of stuff where we're able to pull images to illustrate all
these different procedures and stuff that,
that you would just never go out and get those kinds of photographs.
He would have to kill a ton of animal,
like really expensive.
But we were able to draw back and the advantage of film and hunts for so many
years.
Now.
Is it anything you want to explain?
We'd sit there and be like,
oh,
you know what to be perfect.
And we just go in and pull stills out of images and put them right in the books
we have.
It's like as you look at it as kind of,
you know,
it's beautiful.
Another got a lot of the photography,
like the stuff on the covers by this Guy John Haffner,
who's a hunter and photographer.
Um,
we became friends with John working it up and he opened up his vast library of
wildlife imagery,
um,
just gave us kind of like the keys to his whole catalog.
And so we had just to pick of some of the best stuff out there.
But I'm real,
I'm real happy with it,
man.
I'm proud of it.
And,
and uh,
I always tell people like,
if you get it,
there's,
there's no way you're gonna be disappointed in it.
No,
it's excellent.
It's so comprehensive and it's the,
I don't know of any other book like it.
I mean,
maybe there's one out there that's like it,
but it's,
there's so much info and even if you're not into hunting,
it's really fascinating the tactics and strategies and why you have to do
certain things and,
and what's involved in,
in the,
the pursuit and tracking the habitat of these animals,
why they live in these certain places.
We put a lot of legal stuff in there.
The next one,
that one's out,
the next one,
there's a small game.
One comes out in December.
But yeah,
they've been,
they've been doing well man.
And we've heard great things about them.
Well,
you've expanded
so much,
you know,
and uh,
when I first started talking to you is right after you got done doing the wild
within and then you were starting meeting or at the time and now,
you know,
I really think that the show has hit its stride in a crazy way like this.
The first episode that I saw of this season was the one where you went hunting
for coups dear and you didn't even kill anything and it was one of your best
episodes.
And it was just cause it was so much involved that it just,
it,
it's not just a hunting show.
You know,
like you were talking about your relationship with your father and how you would
love to bring your to this plate.
You know,
your father's dead.
You were talking about how,
you know,
you have this tumultuous relationship with him and how you'd want to bring him
to this place to see what this is like.
Cause it's so beautiful and that in,
there's no music and you were just out there talking and it was like,
man,
this is some really deep,
compelling shit.
Yeah.
We had no,
we had no intention of doing that show that way until later when the editor
looked at it and you're not doing it,
there's no music.
It's just like the sound of the wind.
It was awesome.
It was my favorite episode is mine.
This is my favorite one we've ever done.
And I was nervous at first.
Um,
because you know,
it's a,
to do a hunt shamine you're working in a really traditional genre that does in
many ways doesn't invite a lot of innovation or one might think it doesn't
invite a lot of innovation.
You know,
you could get away with taking that,
but,
but anytime we've done something that really goes against the grain of what you
picture is going to happen in a hunting show,
it's like people that like to show,
I've always liked.
It was like we can run shoulder.
No one gets anything.
You know,
when we're out,
if we're out filming and no one gets anything [inaudible] we call them skunk.
I get real nervous,
you know,
I mean like I started getting real nervous from up from a production standpoint,
but in the end,
man,
I think that people,
um,
that,
that fans of the show are willing to go along with you on that if you're giving
them something else instead.
Yeah.
You know?
Oh,
well you definitely did.
We just filmed like,
we just filmed a dove hunt down in Virginia,
um,
with my buddy Ronnie Bame,
who you met,
you know,
the daily bag limit on doves is 15.
Right.
So it was me and Ronnie and other guy,
we all limit out.
That's a tremendous amount of shooting,
you know,
so then you kind of kill fest.
Yeah.
So you're sort of thinking out of their five ounce birds,
but,
and then you're sort of thinking like,
man,
this is going to be a great show,
but it doesn't.
And that hope that it will be,
but it doesn't necessarily mean that,
you know,
it's like,
it's like having like getting stuff doesn't necessarily mean it's going to be
great because you kind of,
there's always like,
there's always a story hiding around down in there and what we're getting ready
to go somewhere to film.
I'm always getting pressure
in a friendly way from Yannis or from Dodi,
you know,
who are like,
what's the story?
You know,
like what's the,
and I just feel like I understand where they're coming from.
Like is their job to,
to wonder about that stuff.
But I always feel like you're just going to wind up responding to something that
happens.
What I think is important about your show,
I think there's a lot of things important about you and what you represent in
this world.
But one of the things that I think is important in your show is if there's a lot
of these shows,
these hunting shows without mocking them or saying anything bad about them,
but they,
they're very simple.
They're,
they appeal to simple people.
They have like this simple ideology that goes through them.
And I think you get caught in that genre and everybody sort of starts thinking,
well,
this is what the shows are about.
These shows are all about like go sit in a tree stand and you know,
and when,
when you,
you shoot this animal that you named earlier in the spring and you got trail cam
pictures of it,
I mean a lot of those shows are the same goddamn show every week.
Yeah.
And it gets you,
you get it in your head,
oh,
this is what a hunting show is and this is what hunting is.
And I think that's,
it's a problem with the stereotype that people have with hunting.
They connect hunting to sort of a,
like a low vibration of thinking,
you know,
that.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
There you're saying,
I don't know if it's you,
you being a,
a comedian or I noticed you guys always say calm.
It could be in a comic.
I don't know.
I'm guessing you watch other guys.
Yes,
I could see,
I could see in that world you probably would really want to watch other guys.
I haven't found it helpful to watch hunting shows.
Um,
I generally don't watch hunting shows,
um,
because I don't want to wind up.
Um,
I don't want to wind up having to stuff that I do be a response to that.
Right.
You know,
I'm always afraid.
I'm always afraid of that,
of like feeling like something would get in your head and even if you didn't
intend to that you'd wind up responding to it,
you know?
So I haven't watched a whole lot and I don't like to hack on it.
I don't like the hack.
I like people often invite me to like hack on hunting shows and,
and I just don't,
there's some things I see a little bit that troubled me.
Like some of the ways that female hunters are portrayed as like little sex
dolls,
you know,
with the Mascara.
And it just doesn't feel like,
when I think about my daughter growing up and going hunting,
I just don't feel that that will,
I don't want that to be how she finds her way into it as sort of like every
man's fantasy.
That stuff bugs me a little bit.
But,
um,
I haven't followed that help with a watch,
so I don't think of,
I don't do like a reaction to what's going on.
I just try to make things that,
uh,
to,
to show,
just like the complex relationship I had with honey before I started doing this
filming has definitely changed the way I think about hunting and,
and in a way I try to react against that.
I try to recatch like how I used to feel about going hunting when I wasn't
having this production thing in my head about like making a show,
you know,
be worried about making a show.
Well,
I think that it's,
it's,
it's the elephant in the room.
I mean,
how does,
how do you avoid thinking about it while you were out there and you're doing it,
you have to consider,
it's one of the episodes that you did your podcast recently we were talking
about with Casey Casey live.
Yeah.
Well you were talking about,
uh,
all the different aspects of putting together a show and that you kind of feel
like sometimes that filming a show,
in a way,
it kind of,
it's almost like prostituting it.
Yeah.
It makes me feel a little bit evil.
I feel evil for being involved in a,
I feel a little bit evil for being involved in TV.
Partially that's also because your wife is into publishing and she wanted you to
stay within the world of book publishing is a very respected thing.
Whereas TV especially like hunting shows or even reality shows,
which was your first thing,
it's filled with bullshit and your nose.
Yeah.
So yeah,
when I feel a little bit embarrassed,
not,
not so much.
I mean obviously doing that,
and I,
and I loved doing it and I fight to try to keep being able to do it,
but it's like,
it's on the back of my hand.
Like I,
you know,
I do carry that with me.
You know,
I do carry with me that I think of like,
I think of TV as
okay.
Yeah.
It's just as like,
uh,
it just,
it just something about it feels kind of bass man.
You know what I mean?
Well,
I think a lot of that might have to do with your experience on your first show
too.
They were trying to like,
let it fucking moose out of a cage and you shoot it with a mosque.
It,
I mean,
they were trying to pressure you into a lot of really stupid fake shit because
they were operating under the guidelines of,
you know,
quote unquote reality TV because that's how they do it.
What's,
what's important to them is getting the shot.
Not whether or not the shot actually happened.
I remember one time being in a meeting early on when we were starting to work on
that show.
And,
uh,
a guy that I later became friends with and he still does those kind of reality
type shows that come out of Alaska.
But he,
uh,
he,
we were talking about how much time,
you know,
like,
I was ours,
I really need more time,
need more time,
cause it fine and animals.
And He,
and early on,
the first time we ever met,
he's like,
well,
that's why they have wranglers,
you know?
And that was sort of like where that was where we began with that I liked doing.
I,
you know what I liked about it,
doing wow.
Well then,
and it was so many years ago now,
um,
we did eight of them.
I liked,
I fell in love with the,
the guys that I traveled with,
man.
I mean,
like when we quit doing that show and the show didn't get renewed,
they knew we were still filming the last episode and we already knew it was
going down hill.
Right.
Um,
just to viewership wasn't there at the wrong viewership and you know,
or like the v the numbers weren't there and the numbers that were,
that weren't the right numbers,
like not the demographic thereafter.
Right.
Um,
and you weren't going to fix that,
but I had fallen in love so bad with the guys that I worked with that it was
like,
it was like getting broken up with,
by a girl that we weren't going to hang out together anymore and traveled
together anymore.
I mean,
it was bad,
you know,
all these guys,
which guys like everyone,
man,
Mo,
all those guys were on that show.
Yeah.
Moe knew you took him over to don't know.
I know I still,
I still associate with them,
but at the time,
like now I try to wander when I look at that show and there's some good stuff
about,
and there's a lot of bad stuff about it.
Um,
embarrassing stuff about
when I look at it now and I try to go like,
why did I want that to,
why did I so badly want that to continue?
Um,
and I did at the time,
you know,
I really wanted to keep doing it,
not knowing that I would find such happiness doing what I'm doing now,
um,
that I would find such a,
like a,
a sense of peace doing what I'm doing now.
I feel like I'm being constructive and working with good people,
doing good work.
At the time I was just devastated that we weren't going to go.
And now I'm like,
why did I feel that way?
And I think in some ways to just cause I like running around with those guys.
Well,
it's fun,
man.
Look,
we really a lot of fun and we took us to Montana enemies that we could,
like,
there was like a gang of us then we had and we felt like we were surrounded by
enemies.
Oh,
the enemy's being a jackass who all these people around and were like,
man,
if we can go another season and we're going to clean house,
right.
And it's turned us into this perfect thing.
And it was like,
yeah,
we're like,
uh,
I dunno man.
The story of every television too.
We were like warriors,
man,
you know,
I loved it.
Well,
it doesn't feel love those guys.
There's a fun bonding thing that goes with those shows.
It's different than any other show you do.
You film a normal show.
Say if you do like a television show it even,
whether it's on a set or it's on location,
you go,
you film it and then you go either to your hotel or you go,
you know,
back to your house.
Then you show up back on the set in the morning and there's a bonding involved
in that.
But there's a totally different kind of bonding when you're in,
say like when you took us to the Missouri breaks down the Missouri River in
Montana and you're,
you're,
you're in the wilderness together and you're,
you know,
your,
your only source of entertainment is we're sitting around a campfire at night
shooting the shit laughing.
Yeah.
And there's this crazy bond that you have with people when you do something like
that.
And when you're doing it over and over and over and over again like you're doing
like the regular world of civilization seems so stupid.
The Red Lights and the fucking telephone poles,
you just want to just want to give back.
You want to go back to the fun stuff when you're out there in the woods looking
for a buck or trying to find a ram or whatever the fuck you trying to do.
It's like there's this crazy heightened reality to that life that especially
when you have a bunch of men together and you have the opportunity to just do,
it's almost like play time.
Like you have this,
this wild existence,
you know,
and then it gets taken away.
Yeah,
I'm a Klansman and I don't mean that with a k plans and want to see and it's
like,
I do feel like,
like all through growing up I had it like,
well I still hang out.
Like my,
I still consider,
I still regard my two brothers,
like the main people that I hang out with,
you know,
even in a time sense that's not true.
Like in his mind,
like,
you know,
days per year.
That's not true.
But they're like the main thing outside of my immediate,
my wife and kids like my,
yeah,
I think my two brothers are like this main thing and,
but we always had these guys that we hung out with growing up,
the same guys.
We still hang out.
Like just this summer we had people out to our shack or fishing shack and it's
like mostly guys from Michigan that we've known long time,
you know,
and I do kind of feel that,
uh,
that,
that hunting and fishing for me do foreign,
those kinds of relationships,
you know,
and traveling together forms,
those kind of relationships.
I also got to bend good in the military maybe because you get to like have this
little core guys,
you know?
And yeah,
traveling with those guys that I worked with and with,
you know,
and now it's just like the revolving cast a members like face has changed,
but it still feels the same as,
yeah,
it's like this little,
like a little clan,
you know,
like,
click a felon.
Even I do bad.
I'll just like,
I liked that of,
I like hanging out with three or four people out in the woods,
you know,
it's fun.
I mean even me and calendar when we'd done a few episodes with you,
but Cowan was a pastor and media of the night.
He's like,
why don't we go in again when we come going,
honey,
I gotta get Outta here.
He's like,
Let's call it,
let's go on and call Steve.
We were just of this summer,
August 15th we're going to Prince of Wales Island got sunburned.
Sunburnt that's hilarious.
Killed.
Buck's got some.
I mean it was like you wouldn't have believed.
I believe it.
Listen man,
one of the things that I took from those,
so nice.
I was,
if I would have done anything to swap the weather cause going up there like,
yeah,
I got like a,
I got Dan Dougherty mentioned,
I just right now have a,
Dodi had said,
he's like,
I'm never going back to this island,
you know,
and like we're done on this stupid island after our trip.
And we went up there and he was very like,
you know,
he had a very tentative feeling about the weather.
We kept watching the forecast and then when would be a nice,
and we went up there.
I was just like sunshine deer everywhere.
It was perfect.
Not you wouldn't believe it,
man.
It's August.
You've got to go in August.
Is that the move Yanis got Yanis got a buck like doing after hours doing a
little earlier hours.
You're filming.
Yeah.
I took something away.
Very important from that show.
And it's something that you said,
uh,
w w I think you said it when we were in the tent when we were doing your
podcast,
talking about the different kinds of fun.
There's fun.
That's fun while you're doing it like a rollercoaster,
but it's not fun after it's over.
But this other things that are fun way after you doing it,
but while you're doing it,
it's miserable.
Yeah.
That's stole that theory from two guys.
A guy named hardcore Jaffe and a guy named mark and a guy named Matt Raf Rice's
name.
Hardcore Jeff.
So hardcore.
Yeah.
Hardcore.
Jeff Knew Matt Rafferty
in recently.
Someone sent me a link where I think that it had,
I feel it,
it was like a ad of some sort that alluded to that,
like an advertisement that alluded to that,
but it was like a mountain earring thing.
So I don't know.
Yeah.
But I just don't want to,
I don't want to take claim for that theory,
but they had this thing like the four levels of,
you know,
the four or five levels of fun,
these guys out of anchorage,
you know,
and,
and uh,
yeah,
it was profound.
But it's,
it is profound.
And I never thought about it until that trip.
They're like roller coasters aren't fun after you do them at all.
No,
I was on a rollercoaster last week.
Is that right?
Yeah.
So what Brian and last week,
local carnival local,
it was fucking terrifying rollercoaster.
I took photos of the base of it and put it on my Instagram just because it's so
fucking ridiculous.
They have this set up and when you look at this setup,
you're like,
why the fuck did I,
cause it's so bad.
It's like pictures of a him shy,
I'll pull it up.
There's a,
these bricks that they have where a blocks that they have that's holding up the,
uh,
the base of this thing.
It's like at theme.
Yeah.
Well you can see it on the screen a little bit better,
but they have the foundation,
so they have these posts and then a bunch of Shims on the health.
Yeah.
That's fucking blocks of wood.
I mean,
just,
they're,
they're not nailed down.
I mean it's,
it's so fucking ridiculous that you get in that thing and it's spinning people
around 50 miles around.
It's pretty funny.
They just,
whatever they could find a couple of bricks.
It's a full on Carney.
It's cotton and cotton board.
But,
uh,
after it's over and the only thing that's fun is looking at this picture,
but after it's over,
you know,
I didn't even notice that at first.
I went on roller coasters.
Fun in the moment,
but not fun later.
Yeah.
And then just things that are terrifying while you're experiencing it,
but after you survive it,
you're like,
ah.
That was,
that was crazy.
That was awesome.
That trip was a miserable four or five days,
whatever the fuck it was on that island.
But after it was over count and I laugh about that trip all the time.
Yeah.
We just got,
we just got back from hunting in British Columbia and it was,
it was just my feet are still,
because my feet were so cold for so long and my feet are still weird.
Like when I lay in bed at night,
they feel numb really.
And
it just,
I mean,
just generally sucked.
Fog,
snow spent whole days sitting under a tarp cause he can't see anything in the
fog.
Um,
it still,
I plan on it seeming fun later,
but not yet right now.
It's not right now.
I still think it,
sorry,
did I get a couple of months?
I won't think it sucked.
Didn't I call you when I got back to la?
They tell you how fucking awesome I felt you did.
I,
it was a quick turn around.
I was driving around La and the sun was shining like it always is that it was
warm.
Like it always is.
But I appreciated it on a level that I had never appreciated it before because
being rain soaked in that island,
huddles huddling up in that tent and I remember turning on that a little
headlamp and seeing mist everywhere inside the 10 I'm like,
I thought in my stupid head that there was going to be a place
you could go to get dry.
Like you'd go inside the tent and you would get dry.
Well,
it's raining outside,
but that's okay.
You get in the tank,
it'd be no,
there's no dry.
There was no dry.
The air was wet.
The actual air everywhere around you was filled with moisture.
So everything was wet no matter what.
And so when I got back to La,
I felt fucking fantastic.
Yeah.
I was like,
this is amazing.
And it gave me an appreciation for la that I wouldn't have had if I didn't go
through that.
Well,
yeah,
to go home from something like that and then be in bed all warm with like your
wife.
Oh Man.
You know I've talked to you off about Rourke Denver.
No,
he's like was a navy seal officer and ran at Bud's program,
which is like this whole thing.
Like you basically go there to suffer and he was talking about how you think
like you go into a seal's home you think is going to be all spartan.
You know,
like he's sleeping on a stack of cardboard or something.
He goes,
those guys have like,
you go in there,
it's like the Egyptian cotton,
the nicest,
most comfortable homes man.
Because you wind up after like the suffering,
you soap badly,
want to go be comfortable that they go,
he's like,
they go out of their way to have a comfortable house,
you know,
like more than normal people's cause you want to just soak up comfort when you
get the cheese.
Yeah.
It makes sense.
If they don't want to live in a log cabin,
sleep on a futon.
Yeah.
Is it,
you want to go home and lay on really nice sheets because it might only be two
nights,
man.
You know,
you want to get your fill.
It totally makes sense.
Um,
I think having these conversations and uh,
and what you're doing on your show is it's very,
it's very important because it's giving people a different sense of hunting.
It's one of the things that I get all the time from tweets and Facebook messages
and that people change their perspective because of your show and because of
these conversations that you've had on my podcast and because of your podcast,
people have changed their perceptions of it because people who don't experience
hunting personally and they,
their ideas of it a lot of times are shaped by the portrayals of hunters and
movies,
which are almost always negative.
Yeah.
Especially the animated ones.
Like Elmer Fudd.
No.
Yeah.
My kids watch my kids like to show about animals.
Then it's like there's a bad guys.
Okay.
It's,
it's like these two brothers and they have this cartoon show.
Wild Kratts.
Yeah.
So there's like,
the kids loved that show.
Okay.
But there's,
there's like some recurring bad guys.
One of them's a chef.
It's like a chef who's out in the woods.
Like he's always trying to hunt,
right.
The words to make food.
And the other one's like maybe like a,
like a gay seeming urbanite guy.
Yeah.
He's like an evil guy.
Had like a real care guy.
Yeah.
But real like real,
you know,
just like kind of bad,
you know.
It's like your one hand telling you there's two people that are bad kids is gay
guys and and chefs,
Huh?
Yeah.
But want to watch that show.
You won't let them watch it.
No.
I mean they learned,
they learned some good wildlife stuff,
but I'm like I just don't want to,
I'm not going to let it know.
I don't,
I tell him that I tried to explain him why I didn't like it.
They didn't their stamina.
I don't like I'm watching a show.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Like that.
They're like,
I just can't have a show where like the bad guy is like some guy that like a
chef who is always out trying to hide.
Like he's was trying to hunt endangered species.
But that show,
like one of the guys,
I don't know if it's Chris or Martin,
one of them is fat.
I went to,
I took my kid to their live show.
They have a live show in Hollywood.
Oh fucking terrible.
But for five-year-old,
awesome.
You know,
it's like really bad.
They have costumes on,
you know,
they go into their superpowers.
Yeah.
They have like a,
the animal powers activate and they have these like things that they,
they can,
they can assume the attributes of whatever animal they're talking about.
Yeah.
In the show on the television show,
it's cartoons.
Yeah.
So they can do all this crazy stuff.
But I'm going somewhere.
Yes.
The two bros.
And they're jovial.
Very chatty.
Yeah.
They go smart.
And then,
and then the show starts.
Yeah.
In the live show though,
they don't go anywhere.
And so the live show,
they just put on these outfits and it's so fucking stupid.
They put on like big rubber feet.
They pretend to be a fox.
Like it's just ridiculous.
So you're not an of authors and he jumped around on a trampoline and they,
they,
they jump on trampolines to pretend that they have like serval cat powers.
Yeah.
It's in the trampolines hidden behind a rock.
But you can fucking see it.
If I knew that those guys are big vegetarians,
I'd be like,
okay,
that's cool.
Now they probably aren't,
but I don't get,
yeah,
I never even paid attention to the fact that,
that that one guy is a like sort of a hunter or a chef and that's why he's the
bad guy.
Yeah.
I never even paid attention.
You're more sensitive to that than I am.
I'm overly sensitive
when I hear people don't let their kids watch certain shows like because of
whatever.
I'm like the guy,
I don't,
I don't like him watch and stuff.
It has a negative trail on hunters.
That's funny.
Well,
I'm writing this thing right now that I'll,
I'll put out,
uh,
probably,
tomorrow about all the people that got mad at me.
Cause I put up a picture of that elk last week,
um,
that got mad at me and then I went to their Twitter pages or their Instagram
pages and I saw pictures of their cats.
No.
And I'm like,
well you feeding your cat.
Okay,
cause you're feeding your cat cat food and where's that cat food coming from?
Someone's killing animals,
someone's killing chickens.
No surprise.
Some guy is price,
some guy running high seas drift nets.
That to how an international waters.
Yeah,
that to rape and those that,
that's one of the things that,
you know,
it's so easy to fall in the trap of talking about stuff that annoys you.
But that's one thing is like
people that you can have this holier than thou attitude,
like a lot of catch and release.
Fishermen have it,
you know,
they'll go out fishing,
they'll net their trout go and you know those sons of bitches go to a restaurant
that night,
we'll need to order fish.
And you're like,
they don't like,
well who's fishes at yeah.
Was like,
who's very favorite area to that fish come from?
You know,
probably some places a lot more imperiled and where you live.
Well not only that,
the cat,
the reality of catching releases,
what 10% of them die,
20% of them die as much higher.
But yeah,
it's that thing that you like,
you just don't want to be,
you don't want to look at it,
you know?
Yeah.
If you got a cat and you're feeding and stuff like that,
it's probably your proudly support and some,
some,
uh,
you probably support important some fisheries practices that you would,
that you're glad you don't know about.
Yeah.
Not,
and not just fish,
chicken,
lamb.
Well,
whatever the fuck you're feeding your cat,
you're buying cat food and cat foods.
Animals.
Cause cats need protein.
They,
they're not omnivores.
They're predators.
You can't,
I mean,
there's very few arguments.
Make any sense.
You can feed your cat a Vegan Diet.
Apparently you can get away with it.
With some dogs.
They can feed some dogs,
primarily vegetable based Diet.
And the dogs are all right.
They're not,
it's not optimum.
But for cats,
they get organ failure,
cardiovascular failure,
they go blind.
It's a big issue with cats when you feed them,
try to feed him a Vegan Diet to go blind.
Well,
I'd also invite those people,
your critics to understand that those elk wouldn't be here if it were not for
hunter interest.
Yeah,
that's an interesting conversation.
They just would not be here.
Did you?
Um,
I don't know if you've listened to the radio lab podcast on that guy.
Uh,
no,
I didn't.
The line,
no,
I want it to,
I was gone when that happened and there's so many people sent me links to buy,
still having listened to,
but it was about the guy that
yeah,
about some of the complexities of the guy that paid out all 350 grand,
a hundred black rhino.
I had that guy on the podcast and he discussed it and we talked about it and it,
but what's interesting is they,
uh,
had on another guy who was in the radio lab show that was a,
I forget his position,
but he's uh,
uh,
someone who,
works to,
to help wildlife and he was,
he was saying that it's,
the idea is ridiculous that you could kill these animals and that you would say
that you're working as a conservationist,
but you still kill these animals and that you're trying to protect them and make
more of them and let them breed and let them repopulate so that you can kill
them.
I'm like,
that's preposterous.
But the,
the real problem with any of these arguments is you got know,
like I always don't want to know,
like what do you,
do you eat meat,
do you wear leather?
Like how,
if you're making this argument against the hunting of these animals,
like where do you get your protein from?
Are you getting your protein from all plant sources?
Because in that case,
maybe we can have this conversation about that.
But if you're not,
man,
if you're choosing animals that you think are okay and not okay to kill and it's
based on which ones are captive,
that seems to me more fucked up.
Yeah,
it's,
it's way more cruel in my opinion,
to put an animal in a cage and that animal ear marked for death and you just
stuff it and keep fattening it up until you kill it.
And to think that somehow that's a,
that's a,
a better moral decision and going out and killing something in the wild.
But then there's the trophy hunting thing and that's where it gets weird when
you,
you say,
well bill,
these are animals that people aren't even eating.
You know,
like the lion thing,
which the guy,
the guy was just a clear apparently of any wrongdoing,
you know,
I never,
it was so hard to figure out what exactly was going on there.
I would love to know some of the,
some of what was really going on with the,
with the lion then because there's so many claims there were being made that
just in some way didn't add up like that he had,
um,
you heard that they had lowered it out of the park.
Right.
I don't really know what that means now if you could,
because for instance,
and people actually how bad that was that he had lowered it out of the park.
But in the u s
an animal can move across borders freely.
You know,
it was generally illegal.
The fence in wildlife in some way that it can't get away and animal can move
across borders freely and its own,
its public ownership doesn't change when it moves around.
This is something that I've tried to explain a thousand times,
but if you have,
let's take a like some iconic park like Yellowstone national park or if you have
an elk in Yellowstone national park and it jumps a border on the private land
and the jumps,
the board around the federal national forest land jumps a border on the state,
land,
jumps the border and do subdivision jumps a border into a county park.
Throughout all his,
a little journey there,
he's always been the property of the state.
Okay.
When elk migrate out of Yellowstone National Park,
they get hunted.
You know many,
many,
many animals to get hunted and Wyoming and Montana are animals that as part of
the year spend time in Yellowstone national park.
My brother wants drew a big horn sheep tag for the upper Yellowstone valley and
there's this peak near the Gardiner entrance to Yellowstone national park called
electric peak and a lot of big horn sheep spend their summer on electric peak
when he had that tag.
This is in 2005 I think it's quite a while ago when he had that tag.
We're just waiting for snow to pile up
on.
Electric peak in the sheet would begin migrating and they would migrate down and
spend and spend the winter down in some grass,
some like range land up and down the Yellowstone,
so we would go there.
It was on our third trip to the area when we finally found sheep.
We're migrating down out of the high country out of Yellowstone national park.
We killed a sheet within a couple miles,
the Yellowstone national park,
so when people are talking about old,
like the how
the Lion Blonde and the park was of the park was lured off the park.
If,
if you condemn that in and of itself,
then you really talking about something very revenue that would have very
revolutionary implications here in the u s that animals aren't able to freely
move or that an animal becomes the possession of whatever land app that whatever
land administration it happens to be,
but there's a big difference to an animal moving freely when they say it lured
off.
I don't know.
That's what,
that's what I say.
I would love to know,
like I don't know the answer to this.
They the day physically walk into the park?
No.
What they did is they drove around the area,
outside the park with bait and they drag carcass.
They drag your carcass behind a truck.
That's true.
Standard,
but not within the park.
No,
not within the park standard practice.
Not only that.
Lions have a huge area that they traveling and they killed 28 other lions with
tags,
with collars,
and it was never an issue and this idea to this one lion was like this cherished
beloved lion there was only by westerners who are like outsider.
So the people that live in Zimbabwe,
they're fucking all monsters.
They're all terrifying.
Some jewelry,
that guy that wrote that piece in the New York Times is,
we didn't,
we didn't know about that line.
It's critical that when in Zimbabwe we don't cry for lions.
You know what I mean?
That was the name of the piece.
It was all talking about his family members that were terrified where these
people would go outside and they had a very real fear.
They were going to be killed by monsters,
giant cats that will kill everything,
anything to kill people all the time.
You know,
Jim Shockey has this great show called uncharted if you watched it.
Yep.
I know about this show is great fucking show.
And I was watching last night's show.
He was in Mozambique and um,
there's these villagers in Mozambique that are just hunted by crocodiles and
they showed dozens of people that were missing arms,
missing feet,
had giant holes in their head.
We're a crocodile,
had just barely grabbed them.
And these are the people that survived and they,
they all had stories while they were there.
Uh,
a woman was taken into the,
in the water while they were in camp.
One of these women was washing clothes or gathering water and a crocodile came
and got her.
And there's,
there's nothing you can do.
You just shit.
They'd try to kill as many as they can.
They bring in hunters to kill as many as they can.
But to these poor people,
these people were just horrified.
We don't look at that the way we look at lions because they're cold and the
reptiles and,
but there it's just wildlife.
But I think if you got to the point where you were facing where you might be
looking at genetic extinction of the crocodile,
right,
it would change.
Yes.
My thing,
my interest in the,
the the lion controversy that came out of Africa,
my interest in that is provincial in that
I was
concerned about and I'm interested in the way that that's going to impact things
here.
You know,
uh,
not that interested in,
not that,
not that I have antipathy toward,
I'm just not that,
that,
that vested in what might happen with African big game hunting outside of how
people's,
how the American imagination
or the way the average American perceives hunting in his own country,
it here in the u s would be colored by the actions of people in African in the
circumstances that go on in Africa.
That's my interest in that landscape as far as we were saying about the
crocodile thing.
I think that one of the reasons that it's so complicated with the lions is on
one hand we're talking about the threat of genetic extinction of a species.
And I'm sensitive to that here as well because we right now have,
we're engaged in our own thing,
right?
We're engaged in the wolf debate right now.
That in some way mirrors the,
the kind of language we're,
we're hearing out of Africa where you have a animal,
you have a species,
it's absent from much of its range.
Okay.
So there used to be wills,
you know,
everywhere,
everywhere.
But let's just say in the most recent past you had wolves in New Mexico and
Colorado and Arizona.
They're,
they're all over the place.
Wolves here,
California.
And then now they're gone for much of that landscape.
But there are some areas like the greater Yellowstone ecosystem area around
glacier in the u s that have,
what I would say is on the verge of too many wolves.
And so people could look and they'd be like,
well,
how can there be too many if they're extinct across 97% of their range and the
lower 48,
you know,
I'd be like,
well yeah,
it's very complicated.
There are over abundant here and missing from there.
And I see both sides of the debate because a lot of people who might come from
my set of my understanding about wildlife who liked to hunt deer light town elk
like to hunt Moose do want to see the wolves all the way gone.
And what they would point to is the effect that wolves have on,
uh,
livestock,
right?
People's way of making a living.
There's safety implications or not.
But some people say that there are safety implications from wolves being around.
And when I look at them,
I'm like,
okay,
I take all that.
But I don't think that that means we don't want wolves.
I think we do want wolves do we want,
like how many do we want?
You know,
I don't,
I do,
I agree that we want them around.
I just agree that there's a limit to how many we want and what kind of
agreement.
There was an agreement when they reintroduced him that when the population is so
open as far past,
they would open up hunting and then they reneged on it.
So I don't think most people,
it just,
I'm like sensitive to the thing where as much as I was baffled by the Cecil the
lion thing,
I'll a little bit like when there,
when there was the backlash to the backlash and people said like,
Oh yeah,
but you know,
people live in fear,
lions and lions kill people.
I don't know that.
That doesn't really change anything for me.
Like I don't think that that then means that,
oh,
you're right.
We should kill all the lions because they kill people
tweeted the wrong went.
Was it a new link?
Yes,
until yesterday show.
Oh,
it's a different link every time.
Yeah.
What the Twitter or the youtube link cause youtube dot or c.com/c/.
Powerful Jerry.
Slash.
Live.
You must a copy and pasted.
Okay.
All right.
I'll tweet that right now.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Jeremy,
what was different about yesterdays,
I don't know if you copied it from the same place it was at yesterday.
It changes.
I'm sorry.
Keep going.
Steve.
Uh,
lost my train of thought.
Um,
wolves,
blah,
blah blah.
Okay.
Yeah.
You want to keep the wolves alive?
Oh,
that
the argument that like,
Oh yeah man,
it's okay to wipe something out because they hurt people.
Um,
I don't really buy into that either.
You don't know?
I think that striving for with wildlife issues,
I think striving for a happy medium where you can have many different
stakeholders at the table talking about it is more constructive.
And so I think as well with the Cecil the lion deal,
I just think it really like clouded and confused tons of that shit here in the u
s and made it harder for people to imagine,
um,
the role of what I would call management,
wildlife management,
game management.
You know,
because it's not like this,
we no longer live in this Eden environment where you can,
you can act somehow.
Like the hand of man is not at play.
I mean we've,
we've cooked that world
well is the,
the issue that a lot of people have,
a big part of it is this,
this term trophy hunting trophy hunting is deemed to be evil and then people
have respect for people that hunt.
If you hunt for your food,
I,
you know,
I can appreciate that.
But what I don't like is this idea of trophy hunting.
I mean that is a,
that's a giant issue with people.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a semantics issue in some way.
I see it as,
and this is something that I spend a lot of time thinking about and talking
about in recent years is a,
there's,
there's what trophy hunting means to someone who's unfamiliar with hunting.
When they hear the term trophy hunting,
I think what they're,
what they see in their mind,
they see the wanton an animal
just in order to take a piece of the animal it's head or it's hide and have it
as a,
as a bragging rights thing
did.
It's like this like callous slaughter of animals to to take part of it and take
possession of part of it and use it as an emblem or to prove your manhood.
Right?
Like that's what they're seeing.
It's so pervasive now that that meaning of the word
that I think that it might almost be time for people who do engage in trophy
hunting to think about a new term.
If I go out and,
and,
and I hunt and get something,
I do retain some parts of the animal that might be the,
that would be a trophy the same way you have that school right there and that's
gold right there.
Right,
but it was a portion of of what you retained but you eat the animals.
Yeah.
See I think the difference between that and a lion,
because you're not eating a lion and I think that freaks people out.
This idea of just killing something just for its head to stuff it and put it on
the wall when it's not something that you're going to eat.
I they get free.
Yeah.
I think it freaked people out.
The guy didn't eat it.
I W I he should eat in the damn line.
I think you should have eaten it.
He should eat and her found someone wanting to eat it and it apparently he
shouldn't have been a dentist because people love the dead guy was a dentist.
Why?
I don't understand why there's no other occupation where he would've became the
dentist that he,
if he was a welder,
the welder,
they killed the lion.
Yeah.
It would just be that he was the guy with a name.
What is a public practice?
That's a big part.
I'm saying toggle.
No,
it's like there's a thing about peace and just don't want,
there's something people don't like about dentists or somehow that it said
something to the people that he was a dentist.
I don't fully understand it.
People loved pointing out that that man was a dentist somehow it just made it
seem just really egregious.
Well,
one of those guys,
it's like one of the big game hunters that um,
he's got a super,
he's got like the Super Slam and the Grand Slam and he's always on that Tom
Miranda show.
He's a surgeon.
No,
he's a surgeon.
It's like one of the more famous guys that's a involved in the world of a bow
hunting.
He's killed everything that walks with a bow.
It might be,
they have,
you know,
they have the disposable income and a flexible schedule in order to do that sort
of hunting.
Maybe Brian counts.
Dentist is apparently some crazy big game hunter.
No.
All right.
It's a common thing amongst dentists,
but yeah,
I think if that guy,
there's a handful of things that I think could have gone differently if they had
eaten that damn line.
Yeah,
but you wouldn't go kill the deadline to yeah.
Without a doubt.
Audi deadline.
What do you think it would taste like?
Shit.
No,
it tastes like whatever.
Even if I had to take the whole,
I'll take the whole thing and grinded up and make pepperoni sticks out of it.
Dude,
I'd walk around,
I'd come and do a party and be like,
hey man,
I brought you 30 pepperoni sticks,
Bro.
I can feel like he should have,
well,
you hate a coyote on your show.
If he had known,
I think that he,
if he had known what it was going to wind up,
he would have never shot it.
That's what he said.
If he had known it,
he said it.
I think he said if he'd known it had a name he wouldn't have shot.
Yeah.
Well the craziest thing was,
I don't know.
I don't know what that means.
Brother Jericho has,
he had the,
Cecil had a brother named Jericho and they'd said that Jericho was now going to
take care of Cecil's young bull shit.
First of all,
like that's not real.
And second of all,
they thought Jericho had gotten killed because another line had gotten killed
and he attributed,
they thought it was Jericho and then they found out w great relief.
The lion that was killed was not Jericho whose just some no name,
no name that nobody carries cash line,
but it's the idea of giving a lion in name like your dog.
It's not like some wild animal.
All of a sudden it's a pet.
It's a pet that's in a park and that's how a lot of people that don't go to
Africa don't have anything invested in keeping the people around.
They're safe or they have this idea that it's like the lion king and the,
there's some evil hunter is going to go over there and steal decapitated like
the,
the language would they use.
First of all,
they said he shot it with a crossbow.
I saw that and were like reputable newspapers.
Like he didn't use a crossbow.
That's not true.
Decapitated at it.
Well yeah,
that's what you do.
If you want to take the hide,
you have to cut the head off the rest of the body.
Man.
It's like such that issue is such a black hole,
but I think that the people,
I mean it just like has this way and it was kind of the one the ways was most
upsetting to me when it was going on.
Thankfully I was gone for a lot of it,
but uh,
it just had this way of like acting like a black hole or like we envision a
black hole being or just sucks everything around it,
into this thing where it became like the dominant discussion about hunting.
I think that one of the most telling things about it is the people who seem to
be most upset by it or the people who had to least nuanced understanding of
wildlife management,
wildlife politics and wildlife in general and
just the least understanding of what it means to eat meat in the first place.
I looked at all these people that were protesting in front of his,
his dental practice.
I'm like,
you can't tell me you fuckers are vegetarians.
Your big fat,
sloppy faces.
This is,
these are not vegans.
Yeah,
these are not healthy people.
I mean,
this is not people that are eating a bunch of salads.
These are people that probably got burgers on the way to put in those fucking
signs up.
I had an FBI,
I had one,
I had to have the FBI look into a guy who was mass let me a little bit and this
agent came over my house and um,
he was,
he's like,
I can tell you that guy's not a Vegan or he's not a vegetarian.
I said,
the guy,
you're talking about how the guy had just ordered a pepperoni pizza,
which a momma,
I'm like,
dude,
the why you have such a problem with me.
Yeah.
What the Hell you think dad is?
Because it's a target.
You're a target.
There's people aren't looking at things rationally.
I think they're finding green lights.
Like there's a green light.
I'm frustrated by my life.
I don't like my job.
I don't like my social position.
I don't like my,
my whole,
the whole life that I've carved out for myself and I find green lights and I see
those green lights and I could just point my anger in that direction instead of
focusing inwardly instead of looking at what aspects of my life that I should
change.
Maybe I'd have a more harmonious existence.
Maybe I'd be happier,
maybe I'd be more fulfilled.
Nope.
They just find someone like this fucking guy.
What are you fucking,
you're a hunter.
Good Little Bic,
your little Dick.
You're going to fix it with a rifle.
There's like these cliches that they always throw about and then they'll go eat
a pepperoni pizza and it's like,
oh my God.
Do you know what's involved in making pepperoni?
Do you,
if you're ever gone to a slaughter house,
do you know what,
uh,
what,
what existence these animals have before they get snuffed out?
It's a horrific existence.
The existence of a wild animals infinitely better.
And the distance between or the time between the wild animal even knowing that
you're alive and being dead is like that.
I can be tip can be the difference between that and an animal that lives in
captivity and gets turned into sausage or Pepperoni or whatever the fuck it is.
That's horrific.
And the idea that someone who buys cat food,
somebody buys chicken cat food can get mad at someone who goes out and hunts a
grouse or Hunt's a duck.
It's madness.
It's just madness.
I wrote this thing about the hierarchy of um,
of dead animals on social media and I showed what you can get away with what you
can't get away with.
I'm like cut up fish.
Nobody really gives a fuck.
You could show a dead fish and it's a little sketchier like,
but you could show a steak that you've cooked.
Very few people get upset,
but if you show an actual animal that's dead,
people get really upset.
Why do people get pissed about forever?
They don't get pissed about leather couches.
It's kid pulling.
Someone scraped all the fur off.
Exactly.
As soon as you scraped the fur off,
you were like,
that's awesome man.
I'll buy a pair of shoes and I'll take that in a jacket as well.
Can I get a belt if you leave the hair on it.
They fought.
They just do not like it.
Well,
because we're mammals,
it's really disturbing to and leave the hair on it.
They much prefer you to take that stuff and throw it in the trash and then use
it as leather.
But if it doesn't have hair,
like a snake skin belt,
that's cool.
Yeah.
Another thing that really bum me out,
um,
about our,
you know,
our,
our dentist friend,
is that
what I'm talking about Honeywell?
One of the things I'd like to try to promote or try to explain is in a term I
use a lot is trying to form a context
with the land where you hunt and establishing a context with,
with the animals you hunt,
meaning that you understand your place in the world and you understand the world
that you're walking into.
Have you,
have you ever heard of the rider Aldo Leopold who wrote Sand County Almanac?
Yeah,
I've heard his name.
Okay.
Um,
there was not familiar with us when he was writing in the forties,
and he was,
he was kind of the,
the,
he's like the grand pappy of hunter conservationist.
I recently had occasion to reread his book because I went to,
um,
uh,
I,
I gave a talk at the University of Wisconsin.
It was sponsored in part by the Aldo Leopold Foundation.
So I re-read all the Leopold's sand county Almanac,
and he was a hunter in the forties.
And,
um,
relative to the forties,
we live in the good old days.
Um,
we have phenomenal,
phenomenal hunting and fishing here in this country.
Um,
in the forties sucked.
Okay.
In the thirties really sucked.
Um,
there was,
you know,
very few hunting seasons for anything.
Most things were just gone.
Habitat destruction was,
you know,
off the charts.
Uh,
you couldn't,
you could legally hunt turkeys almost nowhere.
Waterfall was just about wiped out dear just about wiped out.
So now,
like if all the Leopold could be alive now,
he'd see a lot that would make him very,
very happy.
Um,
because we've done such a good job on this continent with wildlife management,
but in his book,
he pushes this idea,
he's talking about hunting,
but he's using the metaphor of,
of a,
of a forester.
Okay.
Cause he had been trained in forestry and worked in forestry and he talked about
how a forester,
or you might say a hunter,
um,
goes out on the land and with each stroke of his acts,
his writing,
his signature on the land with each swing of an ax.
And when I say that he's talking about hunting because he's kind of talking
about this in the conversation with hunting.
Meaning when you go out on the land,
you are like writing your signature out there.
You know,
you're,
you're building a legacy.
You're,
you're making decisions and having implications for the landscape impacting it.
What it seemed to be with that guy.
I think one of the things that upset me about that guy,
and that might have upset other people about that guy,
the shot the lion,
was that he seemed to claim,
um,
he,
he seemed to be claiming in some way that he just had no idea,
didn't know where he was,
didn't know what was up with the line,
didn't know the lion,
had a collar and be like,
I just didn't know.
You know,
I think that in some ways,
obviously you're in another country.
It's hard to follow what's going on.
You rely on other people's judgment.
But in some ways I think it was upsetting to people that he wasn't doing,
like he wasn't following that thing that Leopold set out about right.
And your signature on the land because I,
it was sort of like,
he just had no idea where he was,
what he was doing.
And I think that when you hunt,
you do have an obligation to understand your role and your place.
Okay.
And understand the context that you're working in.
What are the limits and the needs of the resource you're trying to exploit?
Can the resource withstand exploitation?
Are you generally behaving as a force that's ultimately for or ultimately
against wildlife?
Like you have an obligation to answer all these questions.
You can go in a situation like that and rely on the judgment of someone else,
but that judgment can get really confused.
I think when money enters the picture,
you know,
but the money thing's funny too because people were very upset.
I was joking earlier about them being them.
I was joking about the dentist thing.
It was just funny the how often it was pointed out,
his occupation was pointed out,
but what I'm not joking about,
his people were very,
very upset about the amount of money,
the traded hands,
which puzzled me because the old narrative
from a century ago was that people of European descent go into Africa and take
resources and pay for nothing.
Did we go there and just rob the place of its resources and we take what we want
and we leave and we don't pay a dime for it.
That was upsetting.
It is upsetting to me now.
It's like he's being criticized for paying too much for a resource is like any
paid or like the guy that he paid 350,000 for a rhino w it would it be better to
you if you paid $5?
It would seem to me that him having expressed the value of the animal in some
way is almost a compliment to the pursuit rather than just going in there and
robbing what you want and never paying for anything.
That makes sense.
But I think a lot of people have an idea,
a real problem with the idea of putting a value on life at all.
Like saying that it's $350,000 you can go kill an endangered animal instead of
the real issue is they that animal was killing w we've talking about the rhino.
Yeah,
the danger.
I'm doing a Brian Williams,
I'm conflating the,
they had a real problem with that rhino.
They had a real problem with these older non-viable rhinos because they were
killing young rhinos.
They killed this rhino had a female and in the,
the NPR piece,
the uh,
excuse me,
the um,
radio lab piece,
they actually found the dead bodies of this female and a male that this rhino
who had killed like they,
he took them to the spots.
The guy who,
the professional hunter.
So you know in Africa they have these things called professional hunters where
you would think,
call them a guide in America.
But they took them to the spot where there's the bones were of this female,
I mean this,
this rhino really fucked this young female to death.
I'm like,
he kept mounting her and fucking her and,
and,
and horning her,
hitting him with his horns and wound up killing her and killed a male who had,
you know,
gotten in the area and wanted to breed with the female too.
So he had killed two other rhinos.
They had targeted him anyway because he was dangerous to the population cause he
was killing breeding males.
The money that had come in from that $350,000 at that guy gave was going to stop
poaching,
was going to protect the environment that this animal lived in.
It was going to protect habitat.
So the,
the argument is real.
It's real weird because on one hand it does seem strange that we're talking
about value for life like that this life would be valuable.
But another hand,
the real value is like you've got to kill this thing anyway because it's a non
breeding male.
Either kill it or you have to capture it and take it somewhere and make it live
in a cage.
But if you kill it,
this guy's willing to pay you $350,000 and he was saying that that was
undervalued and that if there wasn't so much bad press,
they would have probably been over half a million.
Yeah.
If a,
if they had had a park ranger go out or some kind of land manager go out and
shoot it and act like,
you know,
just something that had to be done.
You know,
there would be no pro,
the guy would've been applauded,
but they would lose all the money and all that money that would go
wildlife PR,
the,
the two,
uh,
preservation of the land and protecting of the habitat,
all that money will be gone.
Protecting against poaching.
It's one of those things in life.
It's not clean.
No.
I was reading this morning,
uh,
this article in the New Yorker by Adam Gopnik and he was writing about,
um,
he's actually writing a piece about books about the Holocaust,
but in there he had this line that stuck with me,
or at least it stuck with me for the last few hours where he said that,
um,
something to the effect of the only way to simplify history is to make a
complex.
You know,
it's like anytime,
any real explanation of something,
particularly with wildlife,
you don't get any real aha moments until you get into the deep complexities
surrounding the issue.
I think that's how we can sit here and all these,
whatever number of months after that and I can sit here and still hold in my
hand or hold in my hand simultaneously a disdain
for this guy and what he stood for.
We can talk about the line like some kind of disdain for it.
It's something about it.
I just like,
it's a visceral reaction about some of the things I know about what went on and
what might've been in people's mind and at the same time disdain for the general
public for feeling the disdain that they felt.
It's like I just see it as such a big thing that I haven't really made that much
sense out of it and when I,
whenever I get that conflicted about an issue,
I started to feel like I'm getting somewhere.
That's fascinating.
Why do you feel like you're getting somewhere when you get conflicted?
Because
then I realized that I'm probably seeing it from the necessary number of angles.
Well,
it is one of those things where there are a bunch of different angles to look at
it and it is complex because this guy,
whether or not the Zimbabwe government cleared him of any wrongdoing,
which they did,
he's still tampered with the collar,
which is illegal.
He still was a poacher.
He had been convicted of poaching already.
He had a killed a bear 40 miles outside the area that he cleaned it and kill it.
Tried to bribe the people that he was with two claim that he killed it in an
illegal area.
So this guy was already unethical.
So he was,
he was a perfect guy to pin all this on.
Yeah,
but you want to say like,
okay,
yeah,
this guy was an asshole dude.
Some asshole stuff.
Right.
What does that mean?
That we're not going to manage large predators but,
and I want to be like,
do we have to manage lions?
I mean,
is this a critical issue like it is with wolves.
Like you're talking about the wolf population getting out of control and this is
from a by a biological wildlife management standpoint.
Like the,
the guys who are wildlife biologists gave a number that they think a wolf
population should reach before it should start being managed.
That number's been far exceeded.
And when that number was exceeded,
that's when all the blowback came back where they were saying,
no,
we,
we've changed our mind.
We don't want to open up a hunting season.
And that became a real issue because then the elk population dropped radically.
Then the deer population dropped radically and then there was all these positive
spins on it.
Like did you,
uh,
there was this one guy who,
um,
there's another rate,
a radio law,
the guy that said,
Tom,
the guy that like the how we'll say it.
And it was for,
yeah,
that guy is fascinating because that guys,
I saw that piece and I thought,
well,
maybe this guy has making some interesting points until I listen to this ted,
a podcast about him recently where he's talking about reintroducing wolves or
reintroducing lions and even hippos to England.
Because he thinks that at one point in time,
and it,
you know,
they found in London they found like ancient bones of lions and he thinks
bringing megafauna to of the UK would be beneficial to this areas of the UK.
You know,
millions of Hector's.
Yeah.
How'd he say it?
Hector's Hector's Hector's that are not being used and utilized and they could
turn it into a wildlife park with fucking lions and this is all the result of a
self admitted midlife crisis this guy had,
so he got interested in the concept of rewilding.
I'm ignorant.
I'm interested in the concept,
the rewilding,
and I'm interested in the concept,
the rewilding in that if you can correct mistakes,
if,
if you can correct extra patients or let's say scientific,
you had the ability to correct extinctions,
but just you can't,
so we'll not talk about that for right now.
If you could correct experts x or patients like regional extinctions of animals
that were brought on by human causes,
then I think we have a moral obligation to remedy those mistakes.
Elk,
okay.
The American elk only occupies 10% of its native range.
Elk live in 10% of the land in the u s that they lived in at the time of
European contact.
No one talks about elk being endangered
are near extinction even though they're absent from 90% of their range.
Why is that?
Okay,
because we,
because there are many areas where they abound,
so we've come able to go like yes,
elk are missing from areas and there's a number of groups.
Many state agencies,
most notably the rocky mountain elk foundation work to where plausible bring elk
back to areas in the east that used to have him.
The no longer do in my lifetime,
elk have come back to Michigan,
Pennsylvania,
Kentucky,
and on and on and on through reintroduction efforts.
Okay,
so we're working to repopulate elk.
The biggest piece of resistance you get on repopulating elk is public approval.
People don't want to be inconvenienced,
but big ass animals that they're going to hit with their cars and they don't
want to be inconvenienced by animals eat crops.
So that's the resistance.
The resistance is that it's just that we don't have the technology for it.
It's just that people got to get public approval.
So we're trying to bring them back.
Meanwhile,
we have hunting seasons for elk all over the place.
Right.
I mean just down the line you got elk seasons,
Montana,
Wyoming,
Colorado,
Arizona,
Utah,
Idaho,
California,
Nevada.
While they're gone from other places,
you know,
why is it that we can't extend the same logic to the wolf and say,
yeah,
the Wolf's absent for much of its range and most of it in some of its range,
its thriving.
We're going to manage the areas that are thriving and we're going to work toward
bringing wolves back to the areas where they're not the same way that hunters by
and large,
not even by and large
solely hunters are responsible for bringing them elk back all over the place.
But I think the way the general public looks at things is very different from
the way that you're looking at things.
You're,
you're looking at these animals as a renewable resource.
The general public looks at them as magical creatures that live in the forest.
And that we need to bring back because we made them extinct because we're greedy
and vicious and fall.
Yeah,
we're cause we're,
we're fundamentally flawed.
And on top of that,
we talking about animals you eat versus elk versus animals.
You don't eat wolves.
Why do you want to kill these walls?
You must be a cruel person who wants to go out and kill something and it looks
like a dog cause to people.
Wolves are these magical creatures.
Yeah.
Ooh,
here it.
Well,
you're a wolf.
Wow,
that's cool.
And it is cool to hear a wall,
but I like wolves more than those people do.
Do you think so?
Why do you think you like them more?
I just have more familiarity with them.
I go to more places where they might be found.
I like spend more time looking through my binoculars,
trying to find them.
I just am more interested in them.
I like them more.
It means more to me.
Not every one of them,
but your average guy that's never even laid eyes on one.
I have more of an appreciation for the animal than they do.
I'm sorry,
that sounds like a bold offensive statement,
but I just do it.
I would back you up on that.
I think you do.
But I think I like grizzly bears a whole bunch.
A whole bunch.
I've been hunting for grizzly bears a lot.
Never shot a grizzly bear.
I've never found the one I want to get in.
I will get one in my life.
Are you going to turn into pepperoni sticks?
No.
I'm going to eat it straight up.
Really.
I do get one.
I just got back from spending 12 days looking for grizzly.
Why would you decide to eat it straight up and not turn into pepperoni sticks?
Because isn't it going to taste like shit?
No,
cause I hung them in the interior.
The areas where I go look,
you know,
anytime I've gone out with the intention of getting a grizzly bear,
um,
I go to areas where they don't have access to fish purposely.
Yup.
So that you can get a big on a big one that you want.
I want a mature male,
preferably one who tomorrow will die of old age.
And I want him to not be eating a lot of dead fish so that you can eat them.
Yeah.
Cam Haynes,
I showed you the pictures of the two grizzlies that he shot.
He's eating them now shoe in his way through them.
And I go,
how do they taste?
He's like,
they're fucking awful.
He goes,
I just eat them.
And I'm like,
man,
see I'm not interested in that.
Um,
unless it was for a legitimate wildlife conservation reason and I was going to
eat it.
I don't think I would be interested in hunting something like that.
I mean,
even if it was,
it's just if I'm going to spend my time hunting something,
I want to,
you want to eat it 100%.
That's the thing that,
that's,
that's my connection.
The hunting,
I grew up,
I told her about this handful of times I feel like,
but I'll say it again.
Like I grew up
always hunting since before I can remember.
But for long time I got interested in trapping and that's what I was going to do
for living.
Cause I was gonna be a fur trapper.
I caught my first mosque and I was 10 years old and the trout until I was 22 so
I trapped for 12 years.
And the latter part of that,
I was trying to do it where I was going to be a professional trapper.
All right,
I bet you quit trapping cause for markets got so low.
Um,
and moved away from home,
got more serious about college and started just feeding arm me and friends.
My brothers by that point in time,
we are feeding ourselves on wild game by no protein besides what we hunted for.
Um,
and at that point wasn't what I really like,
sort of found my,
my place in the natural world,
you know,
that was like the relationship with animals and the relationship with the
natural world and the relationship with hunting that
really spoke to me and made me feel very good about my decisions.
Very good about my lifestyle.
And,
and I've lived that lifestyle now,
you know,
for 20 some odd years.
Um,
but I did at a time.
Yeah,
I did trap,
you know,
and I would trap in order to sell the hides.
So one,
I now talk about
why I liked to hunt and then I don't want a hump or something I'm not going to
eat because that's just,
that's why I like the home for it.
I think did some hunters will look at that and act like you're a being divisive,
you know that you're being,
that you have this holier than thou attitude or somehow condemning all their
practices.
I'm just talking about what I like,
my approach will.
I like to do you know what to me is the,
the what to me is the value of an animal.
I think in many,
many cases when it comes to
Predator management,
I ain't,
there are many cases where your PR,
you're going to have harvest of predators that are just not going to,
there's not going to be a food driven harvest,
you know?
It's just not,
we're looking right now like in the same areas that were in the greater
Yellowstone ecosystem around glacier national park.
You're looking at coming up on a thing were to say anything to happen with
wolves is going to probably have to happen with grizzly bears there and many of
these areas,
they're getting way above objective.
Okay?
It's starting to have negative implications for prey animals.
It's having negative implications for people who use the land these bears have.
They're just not afraid of anything.
You know,
you go up in Alaska where grizzlies get haunted.
You can generally get up windows the thing,
let it get a smell of you.
It's going to take off.
Oftentimes,
typically the case in these areas,
they're drawn to the smell of humans.
No one can touch them.
They have ESA protection.
You know,
we had drawn out decades ago what recovery would look like.
We've far surpassed what recovery looks like.
It's gonna happen.
It's gonna be ugly,
but they're going to delist bears,
they're gonna put,
they're gonna dealers,
grizzly bears.
They're going to put grizzly bears,
understate management.
This is inevitable.
They're going to put them under state management and Wyoming,
Montana and Idaho and people are going to be killing grizzly bears,
some,
some limited amount and their probably then there probably is not going to be a
meat salvage requirement on those bears.
Am I going to now condemn that hunting away?
No.
Well you wouldn't because you understand it and you know about it and you
understand the importance of it.
But to the average person,
the average person has a very cursory knowledge,
like very,
very peripheral.
When it comes to wildlife management,
they don't even consider it.
They think of trophy hunting is just being some evil person wants to kill things
again to make their dick hard.
Right.
That's like what?
Isn't that what Jimmy Kimmel said on TV when he started crying and we started
talking about Cecil?
No crying.
No,
I heard about the cried and he,
he did the whole cliche we talked about,
is that what you need to get your gift card?
I like that guy too.
Well,
I do too.
I like them a lot,
but I just don't think he understands.
I don't think he understands.
I don't think he educates himself about it and I think he worked 16 hours a day
on a show and I think he has very little knowledge about what it takes to manage
wildlife.
Now this is coming from someone who doesn't agree with the lion hunting,
that guy like I don't think the lion populations are low.
I mean,
or high rather.
I mean I don't think it's anything where you have to manage.
I mean I don't think that's the,
the issue that they're having in Zimbabwe.
I think this is just a,
it's a,
a way that they make money and there you can look at it that way.
Like it's sustainable and if it is sustainable and these people use it too to
make money and they benefit from the resource of people coming over there and
hunting them,
I guess you could see a positive benefit of it.
You know?
Did you ever see the Louis Theroux documentary on those hunting camps,
the high fence hunting camps in South Africa?
No,
it's pretty good.
It's [inaudible].
You told me about it and I really nailed to ever watch it.
Now I'm going to Redo it instead of rewriting it down in my notes.
It's excellent,
but one of the notepad,
I'm going to write it on my note.
All right.
One of the craziest parts of it was the lions.
They had this fenced in area and it's a small area where they have these lions
and they're throwing these cows literally over the fence there in the back of a
truck and they have this high fence and these lions are staring at them.
Fucking ruthless killer eyes.
I mean they are right there.
There's two sets of fences and K,
you know there's like a in case one of them fails because of the fence behind it
and they chuck these lions,
this cow,
this calf,
they throw it over the top like fucking Jurassic Park and they just tear this
thing apart and they looking at and will eventually while some guy goes and acts
like he's hunting the lions.
Exactly.
They're going to let one of those loose.
They let them out of the cage and lions are used to their territory.
Right?
So when they let him out of the cage,
the lions are going to get out of that cage and they're going to go,
where the fuck am I?
I'm just going to sit down here and try to figure out where the hell they are.
Right.
So they're going to sit down and then they send this hunter out in the hunter,
finds the line,
shoots it poses,
does the whole a picture with it.
And you know that guy pig man did that.
They had a whole episode and he's,
he's going and you can tell these lions have just been released.
He doesn't.
Does he show what he was doing that was not
high fence?
This thing I don't understand about guys like Todd high fence.
Why do they,
why do they love the trappings of hunting?
The appearance of hunting,
the methods of hunting,
the tools of hunting,
the close of hunting,
the photographs that come from hunting.
Why do they like that so much?
But they just don't like hunting the doing of.
Is that what it is or whether they want guaranteed success and do they want to
hide the fact that it's in a high fence environment because they're doing it on
television and don't things like the outdoor channel,
don't they have rules?
We have rules like you can't show high fences,
you can't show fences on television whether or not you could show,
do you feel like
show it.
But I feel like people are often doing non fair chase hunts but masquerading,
yes.
Did it was a fair chase hunt if you like to do [inaudible] aren't fair chase if
you like doing it,
why do you,
why do they have such a hard time just saying that's what I'd like to do.
Well I spent an enormous amount of time explaining why I like to do what I do.
You know,
why don't,
I would love for one of them to explain to me what they like about it instead of
doing it and acting like they did something different.
Well,
per part of it is the network themselves,
right?
The outdoor channel and the sportsmans channel,
they don't allow you to show high fences.
That's part of their bio lines.
Right.
I don't know if they say don't show high fences,
they might not want,
this is coming from Ben.
Brian.
Yeah.
So they might,
they might,
I can't say if they say don't show it or if they're saying don't do it.
I think they say don't show it.
Don't show it.
Because I can't.
Nugent is on that program.
Right.
He's on those networks.
He's got a huge show on that network.
He hunts in his fucking yard.
I mean he's not,
he's not on a big piece of property.
I think he's less than 300 acres or maybe 300 acres.
That's not that much.
And in that 300 acres,
it's all high fence.
He's got African animals,
got all kinds of shit and they're white tails.
Pig's all in this one area.
And he hunts high fence almost exclusively.
And when he's hunting on it,
you know,
it says like spirit wild ranch.
That's his yard.
I mean he's essentially hunting has pets if you really want to look at it that
way.
And then he used his house goes,
sits in his favorite tree.
Stan probably got a bunch of them all over his property,
but I don't,
I don't think he's proud of,
I think in and of itself,
I don't feel there's anything wrong with that because my brother raises sheep.
Right.
And when he goes out to get the sheep,
he goes out with a 22 he's got irrigated pasture,
he runs lambs.
When he goes out to get a lamb,
he gives a lot of it way eat some of it for herself.
She was the land with the 22 however,
he doesn't dress it up like he's hunting the lambs out on his pasture.
Like it's a wild animal is going to sneak up on.
No,
I mean he does.
He doesn't like put,
he doesn't like put a picture of him in his 22 on in a dead lamb on face,
but he's like heart.
You know what I mean?
He's a hunter.
He's a very avid hunter and never once in his life.
I wish she was here because I'd like to ask them this question.
Never once in his life.
Has He confused the act of farming
organic sheet with the act of hunting wild elk?
It's not confusing to him.
No.
But is it confusing?
Like which house did you have a good hunting year?
He'd be like so far he got an elk.
What does Bo on national forest land,
he got an antelope with his bow
and he would never be like,
oh,
and I got 10 lamb in my yard.
Yeah.
It's just like,
I already did it.
It's just so weird to me that I feel like we talked about this,
a dog during to Doug during has to go out now and then and kill cattle on his
farm.
He doesn't like get gussied up and Cam oh and get like a bunch of pink accents
and like put pink accents all over his gun and go out
and go out and like shoot the cows on his property.
Right.
It'd be like,
no,
I wouldn't shut my cow.
Right.
He wouldn't make a TV show where he's like acting like he's hunting is cows,
but his fence is only,
you know,
20 yards.
Whereas Ted Nugent's fences,
300 acres.
Yeah.
I can't really speak to it cause I just,
I'd have to go see it.
Right.
Well I haven't seen it.
You know,
you only see it on the show.
You see him,
he takes around one of those little ATV vehicles,
you know,
the little things Brant and drives around and is,
it's beautiful piece of property.
It's kind of a cool way to acquire your meat.
You know,
if you have all these animal,
you 100% guaranteed.
There's animals there.
Yeah.
You know,
it's not like there's a big search,
you know,
you're like,
fuck yeah,
let's,
uh,
let's keep hiking.
You know?
But it's so weird.
Cause if my brother all sudden told me the one who raises sheep and Alex like I
keep,
I'm gonna explain the sheet thing a little bit better.
This might be interesting to your viewers,
your listeners.
He has pack llamas.
Okay.
He uses llamas.
He liked hunts back country for elk,
right.
Very,
very remote areas.
And Elk are big and he hunts by himself.
So he keeps llamas to carry his elk meat.
So he'll go in the mountains with his bow and he'd go in there for a long time
sometimes and when he kills an elk,
he can put the whole bowl on three llamas and pack the l out of the mountains.
He hunts some areas where he's nine miles from a trail head and he did that
because he fucked his backup,
carrying it out himself,
take care of you,
help me.
That's when he first got motivated by llamas.
Now cause he has llamas,
he bought irrigated pasture to keep the alarms on its flood irrigated,
but he's gone a lot,
so incentivize his bodies to come over and check on his lamas,
make sure everything's cool.
He lets them run sheep with the lamb and so they come over to watch,
to check on their sheep,
thereby checking on his llamas.
Now,
if he told me one day,
if all of a sudden he said,
hey man,
let's get all done up in our camel and I'm going to put a blind out,
I'm going to put a blind out what the sheet and let's sit in there and shoot
arrows at the sheep.
Right?
I would just think it was weird.
Yeah.
It's not like,
it's not like the,
I think it was like moral stuff,
right?
We have things in our lives that are just like moral obligations.
I feel like you have like a moral obligation to take care of her children.
I think if you're not taking care of your children,
I think you're like,
that's an immoral move
for my brother to go out and like decide that he wanted to shoot his bow at the
sheep on in his pasture would just strike me as just strange.
Yeah.
It's definitely strange.
But is it strange to stock upon with fish?
You have a small pond?
No,
in fact,
in fact his neighbor just dug a big fish pond.
Right.
But isn't that the hierarchy?
Oh,
the hierarchy of animals.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's just,
it's,
I can't explain it.
You won't type post something to me that still troubles me.
Now we're talking about Batan.
When I was a kid,
we baited dear.
I now realize that we had done a hell of a lot better deer hunting had we not
gotten involved in that.
But I was just how when I was a kid,
we'd go to this town,
grant Michigan,
they raised a lot of carrots and grant Michigan and you could buy,
they'd size the carrots and sort the carrots and you could fill the back of a
pickup truck.
It seems outlandish now.
I'm 40 years old and this was when I was 12 you could fill,
they would fill your truck with carrots for $5 I mean the bed of a pickup.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
The bed of a pickup would be full of carrots for five bucks.
How the fuck did carrot farmers make any money?
I and I never understood it.
There was a time when they were harvest and he'd go down there and they would
just,
you'd pull up on your grain hopper type thing and to fill your truck with
carrots.
Oh.
Sudden I want to care it.
We'd sit in the back.
Dude.
We'd sit in the back eating carrots,
man.
You'd find care.
It's like all the look like you could find care that look like humans.
You can find curious.
The Genitalia.
I mean just parents are crazy.
I'm like,
I have carrots,
my garden,
and you pull it,
the carrots,
your eyes,
you expect you're going to pull up the thing that looks like a care from the
store.
One in 10 yeah,
one in 10 most of them are like three legged carrots,
so they had it down a little better than I do and they had better care.
It's been,
we get always rejected carrots.
We'd have a snow shovel and we would go out to areas behind it and we would put
down a canvas tarp.
I can picture the tire right now.
We'd lay down a canvas tarp and you'd snow shovel carrots out of the back of the
truck onto the tarp or into what's known as the Duluth pack,
big canvas leather strap backpack,
and we would hike,
either drag the carrots on a tarp if possible,
or loading and backpacks and hike them back into the intersections of deer
trails.
Typically we're too big deal trails that come together and you dumped the
carrots out and then you do this a week before season and then you punt.
You'd sit in the tree,
stand with your bow,
you're picking the area,
the deer frequent anyways,
you're picking like,
uh,
like I said,
usually typically like a confluence of a couple good deer trails or pit area
where deer might stage up in the evening before going out into ag fields to
feed.
You know,
they kind of will mill around a little bit oftentimes before committing to a
field at nighttime.
It's set him up in these areas.
Um,
the problem is as soon as you put down the carrots,
you'd be creating problems for yourself because they would start to associate
the carrots with hunters.
Like they knew trouble's brewing your smells around,
you got deer.
You know,
doe can be,
I mean,
they can get really old,
but let's just be realistic.
And you got all kinds of deer doles around that are five,
six,
seven years old.
You accumulate a lot,
a lot of knowledge in that time.
So you put the carrots down,
you're kind of screwing yourself,
but you would get shots,
young deer that would come in to hit the carrots.
So I grew up hunting bait.
Now I look at it and be like,
man,
I would have learned a hell of a lot more about deer and a lot more about deer
hunting early on if I hadn't gotten,
if I hadn't been involved in that practice,
I now look back.
I'm like,
man,
did I miss a lot of chances to get educated about what do you need and how to
actually find deer instead of trying to manipulate their movement patterns,
you know,
so now I don't hunt.
I don't hunt bait anymore.
I'm not even kind of interested in hunting bay and I was explaining this to you.
This is a long ass story.
I was explaining this to you because you were like,
well,
why is it okay to use bait when you're fishing?
Yeah.
I don't know.
It is a way I wish I could explain it.
It's more sporting in my mind to use.
I hate that word.
No,
I don't hate that word.
It's more sporting in my mind to catch a fish with bait than it is to catch them
in a sane,
each sane.
Don't you hate that argument though,
that people say you're a real man.
Why don't you go fuck and fight that animal one on one?
Once you what you were with a sniper rifle sitting around with a rifle,
shoot silly.
Why don't you go hit it with a rock?
Praise your bare hands.
Crazy horse had a rifle.
Did he?
Well he's an Indian or saying like forgiveness or whatever people have.
Yeah,
I'm just saying like if someone was posing that argument to me,
I would point out how people that hunt for their food have
always gravitated toward technology.
And if you look at our progression from rocks to have to do rocks to add
laterals to Bo equipment,
to Flint,
locks to percussion,
cap to paper,
cartridge to rifling on down the line.
I'm not doing anything that revolutionary by using what an effective means.
New Ideas.
It's abating.
It's a new idea.
Yeah,
but it's not interesting to me.
Right.
I'm talking about interests.
Like I like knowing about animals,
right?
I'm not interested in there.
Let's take the area right there.
I want bears.
I want bears in the coastal area.
Okay.
And is that a northern latitude?
There's a lot of snow there,
but because of maritime influences,
you know it's warm enough down around the water where it snows melted off in the
water.
So when I go to hunt bears and the spring,
90% of the landmass is covered in snow and is of little use to a bear.
Okay.
When they come out of hibernation,
they're going down to the waterfront cause on the waterfront they're gonna find
beach ry and some other grasses they like to eat.
They're going to find blue mussels and they liked the crabs under rocks and
logs.
Now.
So I know about Mussel beds and grass flats were bears are going to go to all
the time.
I can tell you when we go out at night,
I can tell you,
I'll be like,
we'll see more than one,
probably less than five.
And I'll tell you and I know and I know some Mussel beds where some are going to
show up.
I like that.
I don't like,
I've never done it baited bear hunt.
I have no desire to do a Beta bear hunt.
Is it?
Does that mean it's super hard to hunt bears where I hunt bears?
I can't tell you that.
It's super hard to hunt bears there because once you learn the rhythms of the
land,
what they want,
why they're coming there,
what they're coming to get,
it becomes easier and easier.
The more you understand bears in,
the more you understand why bears do what they do,
but I like having that knowledge,
but I can't say it's like super hard.
It's not super hard.
Once you know it,
it's pretty easy.
So when I say I don't want to go hunt bears over bait,
personally,
I'm not saying,
oh,
because it's so easy.
I'm just saying because it's just not of interest to me.
It's like it's not interesting to me personally as a hunter that bears will come
to donuts if you put them out in the woods.
It's not an interesting phenomenon.
What's interesting me is they like muscle beds.
Like for whatever reason,
I find that interesting.
When I lived in Michigan,
my brothers,
each drew a black bear tag,
a Michigan,
you could live your whole life in Michigan,
which has a lot of barriers in the north and never lay eyes on a bear because of
the landscapes flat and it stick.
If you want a Honda bear there,
yeah,
you're going to either have to use dogs,
you're going to have to use bait because that's the way the landscape is.
So when they drew bear tags,
I helped them run Bates,
I helped them collect bait.
We shot carp and all kinds of stuff and froze bait and trap beavers and baited
bears form.
It was the only way to do it.
I had a blast doing it.
But right now,
no,
it's just not interest
me.
Well,
in Alberta they have two places that they hunt bears,
they hunt bears over bait in the spring.
And then in the fall they'd go to these,
uh,
open fields where they find blueberries and the open fields,
his rifle hunting most of the time.
And then in the Bates,
they most of the time use archer.
Yeah.
And you can bring them in close and,
and figure out what size they are.
Exactly.
Not Kill or not kill solves with cubs.
I understand that.
Yeah.
No,
but I understand what you're saying too.
It makes total sense because what you're doing is you're going to places where
they would be no matter what without human influence whatsoever.
They would be there for those muscles.
They'd be there for those grasses.
And so you are,
you are experiencing the actual natural progression of them waking up from their
hibernation and heading down to feed.
You're just going where you know they will be and it's not,
there's no donuts,
there's no cookies,
there's no bullshit,
no fucking big blue jugs that are set out for them to pour it and try and get
their boats out of.
Yeah.
There's something less cool about that.
Like uh,
like,
like elk hunting on elk hunting in Colorado or overhear and to hone ranch when
you're,
you're out there,
those animals would be there whether you exist it or not,
they're out doing l type stuff.
They're,
they're out breeding and eating and you just,
you're just trying to find them,
locate them,
and then put a stalk on one and get one.
That's a pure way of doing it for sure.
But then there's people that would argue,
you know,
like the,
the argument of,
well,
you're using a rifle,
how hard could it be?
You know?
And then there's other,
although also people would say,
well,
you know,
I prefer to hunt with a bow because it's more difficult.
Like what you're talking about is more difficult.
But then there's also people that were saying,
well,
if you hunt with a bow,
you have more of a chance of wounding and animal and not killing it.
You should,
you should use a rifle.
I mean,
you're not going to make everybody happy no matter what.
No.
The difficult argument is it gets really circular and hard to pin down because
if you say,
you know,
I,
I don't,
I hunt with a compound bow.
I liked the cause.
It's more,
it's harder than hunting with a rifle.
Then you'd have to go,
okay.
Then by extension,
the recurve,
and if you're gonna do that,
you should hunt with a long bow.
And then if you're going to do that,
you should hunt with an adult ladol,
which is certainly more difficult than the long,
like the throwing board of the dart.
Oh Jesus predated the predated the bow.
The Bose only like here on this continent,
they,
you know,
the bowls only been around for people debate it,
but somewhere between four and 6,000.
So you had 10,000 years.
The human history are more here where they're hunting was addle addles I bet
there was skinny as fuck guys hunting woolly mammoths.
They weren't hunting willy mammals.
The bows.
Wow.
You're home with adult.
So that's that,
that thing where you put the spear on it and you know,
it's kind of like go cop in the exact,
put a couple fingers in there or some kind of holding board and you fling a
spear or those,
it makes your arm.
Yeah,
it's like a big ball.
It makes,
it's an extension of your arm and makes your arm essentially longer.
How would you go when you go to people to a dog park and they're hawking tennis
balls that little.
Yeah,
that same thing.
It's like an ad Aladel principle.
Right?
So yeah,
there was for you know,
10,000 years people hunted here with atlatls.
How accurate are those things that I've seen guys get good man.
Really?
Yeah,
I've seen guys get good.
How much distance can get it'll teen 20 yards tops tops.
Yeah.
I'm sure it's some guy was like,
oh,
did do it.
But yeah,
guys that kill stuff with allows kill stuff.
Adults,
the thing that's going on right now,
like people are doing that like that.
But the problem is there's,
that's why guys,
a hunt with Adelaide hills will tend to hunt wild pigs or other things like that
because most places you can't use them.
Oh,
okay.
So you could do it with wild pigs because they're considered a nuisance and some
areas,
yes,
you can use all their means to kill him,
but most states they don't.
All states have somewhere they spell out legal method of take.
It is,
we looked into this once.
I think that it,
like in Alaska,
I think for the most part,
like yeah,
you could hunt Caribou with an adult.
Adol I could be wrong,
don't know and go out and do it because of that.
Remember looking at the way it's worded,
and I think you could hunt Caribou with an adult model,
but state spell out legal method of take in exquisite detail.
For instance,
hunting waterfowl,
which is waterfalls,
federally regulated and state regulation,
because they're migratory,
they move across state lines.
So the feds step in to try to make sure the states aren't taking more than their
equal share of the resource.
Now they'll spell out the diameter or bore of the shotgun you're allowed to use.
You can't use an eight gauge,
you know,
and then they'll spell out you can't use,
you can't use anything bigger than a 10 and you can't use anything smaller than
or whatever,
you know,
for 10 or something less than that are not allowed to use it for 10 so they'll
spell on a squeeze it detail what you can and can't do for legal method to take.
So a lot of what I'm saying about if you want to go back,
back,
back in time to have things get more and more and more difficult.
It's hypothetical because the guy that is doing as far as weapon choice,
the most difficult thing you can legally do for general big game hunting in the
US for a weapon choice would be that you'd hunt with a longbow cause you're
still legal.
It's still illegal method.
Take for most archery seasons to hunt with a longbow.
Um,
so if you want to cripple yourself or handicap,
I don't want to say crap,
you want to handicap yourself equipment wise.
The guy who uses a longbow is going way.
Now,
I recently looked at an ad where a guy is getting out of a helicopter
in
space age,
dress with a longbow.
So we all,
it's a hunting clothes ad.
Okay.
So we all find our little ways of mental masturbation and this isn't just
something to happen.
This is like an image that they thought his cooler.
Hell yeah.
Feel like it's so cool.
It will be the front of the catalog is climbing out of a helicopter with a
longbow.
So we occupy the [inaudible] and in the U s for the most part,
like in Alaska for instance,
you can't hunt with a helicopter.
You can't use a helicopter to supply a hunting camp.
You can't scout for animals from a helicopter.
We decided it's just not fair to use helicopters because you can land them
anywhere you want and you can't hunt for the most part.
You can't hunt and fly on the same day.
Just not fair.
But here's like a longbow and a chopper.
So we all come up with our ways of,
of,
of finding comfort.
Yeah.
You know,
our ways of finding that right.
Mix of challenge,
not challenge.
I heard a guy say,
people have really struggled to define fair chase.
And I heard someone recently,
I don't think it's a new thing,
but I heard it recently where he was saying that in fair chase,
the animal has a better than 50% chance of escape or something to that effect.
My brother's a statistician.
Um,
he's an ecologist but he does,
uh,
he,
he specialized in like statistical modeling and I asked him what he thought of a
statement like that and he couldn't even find the language to begin telling me
how stupid that was.
That it has a 50% chance to escape like under what requirements?
Right.
Or like,
like he like made his head like smoke come out of his ears when you heard that.
But what the guys trying to get at is this idea that you have an [inaudible]
that there's an unknown element,
right?
There's not guaranteed success is not guaranteed.
When my brother goes out to shoot his sheep,
it's a hundred nos.
Yeah.
Did it's time to shoot the sheet.
Right now,
this is the same guy that recently spent 21 days hunting elk would his bow on
national forest land before he finally got a bolt.
And he's very good elk.
He uses a recurve though,
right?
No,
with a compound bow.
Which brother?
Matt.
So does Danny uses recurve or did he shoot a recurve but it mainly haunts or the
rifle.
Did Matt decide at one point in time he was going to use only a recurrence?
The brother was the one that Danny,
Danny is more and more interested in hunting would is recurve.
He does Hellmann's recurred,
but he all,
I mean he just,
he,
he drew the same,
a copper river tag
that I drew in 2004 and two days ago.
He got a buffalo up there and he shot,
it was,
he got over his rise.
So did he go by himself for 21 days?
Okay.
My brother man.
Yeah.
Wow.
In the car and it was a couple of different trips added up to 21 days.
It was just trying to locate the right bowl or trying to locate any bull.
Just haunting and bowl.
Yeah.
But he yawns and a very,
he haunts in an area where there's about,
is that the herd?
When we started hunting that area,
this is in Yellowstone.
It's kind of funny now looking back at the return to this whole wolf thing,
it's like,
you know,
the greater Yellowstone ecosystem.
Okay.
The guy he law say that the,
the area surrounding Yellowstone and Wyoming and Montana,
we started hunting that area in 97 now it seems like dislike,
you know,
it was profanity,
right word.
Now I was like this watershed moment because right when wolves,
right that's right around the reintroduction of the wolf.
Um,
okay.
There is now less than half as many elk in that area is aware of the time we
started hunting it.
But he's way more than twice is good hunting them now.
Yeah.
So how he's grown and developed as an El Conor,
he has a higher success rate now hunting half as many elk cause we used to hunt.
Okay.
That's fascinating.
So because knowledge.
Yeah,
cause he just learned it.
He's one of the great,
he's one of the best hunters,
but I know and it's not because of any particular thing,
it's just the tenacity thing.
He's tenacious.
Well,
speaking of tenacity,
you,
that's one of your qualities as well.
And one of the things that I found fucking unbelievably ridiculous about your
show was when you made a decoy of a grouse.
Yeah.
And you tried to figure out whether or not you could you,
you,
you had someone make a reed,
I mean,
a grouse for people that don't know is a very small bird.
Blue rouse though blue graphs at big small bird will big like what is it,
half pound?
Yeah.
Does it even know,
I mean,
doves almost a half pound.
No.
How much does way a few pounds.
Oh,
it does if a few columns.
Okay,
so a football size,
how big is it?
Yeah,
the body.
But yeah,
that's a decent size.
Bigger in order to be,
if you plucked one out,
it'd be like a not fat Cornish Game Hen.
Okay.
So very small chicken.
I'll let you,
you,
have you seen my chickens?
I got some really some of,
um,
we,
we've got a couple really tiny chickens.
Yeah.
Tony were like us.
He knew he had a blue grouse is his seeming we bird.
Okay.
You know what,
that they're,
they're not as heavy as a pheasant,
let's say.
Okay.
They're not as heavy as a cock pheasant,
but meanwhile you spent fucking days trying to figure out how to more
effectively hunt.
It's one little thing.
Yeah.
I became obsessed with,
yeah,
I use that word was such hesitation,
man.
I became of,
yeah,
it's like,
it's a good word because we used to fully concentrate upon,
yeah,
so there's this bird,
um,
who called the blue grills?
No,
Blue Ross used to be used to know blue grouse
is Dusky grouse and Sodi grouse and it's the,
it's um,
then for a long time they lumped them together as blue grouse and then in,
in a decade ago or some time,
maybe 97 or sometime around there,
no,
I'm sorry,
2007.
The ornithological society realize that there is a difference between the
different species,
the different types of blue grouse and they re split them or they suggested that
they'd be reread,
split into cities and duskys.
So you have Dusky grouse or in the interior mountain ranges and city graphs from
the to ranges.
And there is a normal bird,
people call them fools hands and they call them dumb birds and all this kind of
stuff because they don't,
when they think of the things that they're afraid of,
they're just not afraid of people.
They don't have much exposure to people.
They live in pay at places where most people don't go.
Um,
so when a Predator approaches,
when human approach,
what they typically want to do is jump into a tree.
They want to get off the ground so they can't get nabbed by a bobcat or a fox or
a coyote.
And they get under some limbs in a tree.
So the,
so the avian predators can't smack them.
And then people walk up and there's this bird sit in the tree and they shoot the
burner.
Like,
Oh that bird stupid.
When in fact the bird is not,
the bird has his way of surviving his typical threats and it has having adjusted
to human predation.
Cause there's just so little of it on them.
Um,
we used to hunt bears black bears in the spring on avalanche slides because when
the mountains are all snowing,
you get an avalanche slides that they're swept clean of snow.
And those areas are the first to green up because the snow slid off and it
doesn't need to melt off.
And so embarrassed come out of hibernation.
They'll come and find those avalanche chutes and feed out him.
And we used to sit just at the base of an avalanche slide all day waiting for
bears to come out and doing this now.
And then in the spring you'd hear this noise that would go who?
W?
W,
w.
W.
And I can never forget the hell it was because I was brought up in Michigan
where there aren't these girls don't live.
Eventually realize that it's,
it's a blue grouse and that's their mating call in the spring.
Is that who it's haunting.
What's haunting about it?
You can't tell what direction it really came from.
A couple of years ago,
I was out on a reveal the island or reveleigh Giga Doe Island in Southeast
Alaska and we were messing around there one day and we got up on this big high
ridge and I could hear five or six of these things going off,
you know,
w w w and I just thought,
man,
we'd come back here and pound them because Alaska is the only place you can hunt
these birds in the spring.
They call it the spring hooter season.
Um,
I thought I'd just be a matter of going up there and here in it and walking down
and getting it.
So we even talked about doing an episode.
It was 22 minutes long with no tape,
no cuts.
It would just play straight time from the time you heard one
to the time you shot at time it out.
So we would just run a continuous loop of film.
Now we went out and started looking for the first burden and about like 10 hours
into trying to find the first bird.
We realize you are not going to do that.
Can't find them,
but you can.
I learned how then very difficult to find them because it's just a ventriloquist
sound.
It's just like you can't locate the sound.
I had a guy,
is there a game call company where I knew some guys called down and dirty game
calls and I sent them a bunch of sound recordings that are on the Cornell
University website.
They have this all like everyone McCall the library of bird sounds.
I sent them some of the sounds that the females make and the females make noise.
It sounds like it's almost like,
and uh,
they made me a call that sounds like that.
And I played the other,
the male sound,
the w w sound to musician friends and people that have been like,
what in the world would make that sound?
And people talked about this Australian instrument that my degree duty.
Yeah,
they said that,
that you could maybe use that.
We tried beer bottles,
all kinds of stuff.
I like blowing over the top.
Yeah.
Could never make it satisfactory sound.
But I got to where I was making a female sound and in this guy I know in Utah
named Shad Brunson,
um,
got me a female blue grouse and I had to go to a tax nerd,
misnamed Colton in Montana and he stuffed that blue grouse for me.
Just a real rudimentary stuff job.
And I took that thing out and I would,
I would hear why I could hear a bird by,
couldn't tell where I was hearing it from,
but I'd get where I kind of knew I was in the area he was in and set that decoy
out the hand and then make the call,
like attending call that they make to their young nick,
nick,
and um,
nothing,
nothing.
They didn't give a shit,
couldn't,
couldn't call him in.
Uh,
yeah.
And uh,
man,
it was just really frustrating.
And then I wound up
finding,
I was so pissed about how this was going and sold,
like baffled that I couldn't find these birds.
I called my brother who put me in touch with a body of his,
who put me in touch with a buddy of his,
who knew a guy who knew a lady who was very,
very good at finding blue grouse
and she's audit Juneau,
Alaska.
And uh,
I went hunting with her and we were standing under growls and to treat by nine
30 in the morning,
the first day after spending four days.
Okay.
And found a bird one bird.
Yeah.
She and I,
we were together for three days.
I think we've found 15 of them.
She just knew how to find them.
When she hears that noise,
she's hearing something to,
I don't hear.
Wow.
Well that's a tenacity I'm talking about.
Yeah.
She's got it bad.
Barb
is a tenacious,
tenacious hunter.
But you know,
my older brother I,
but he's got this term,
um,
he talks about people having girl girl,
like,
yeah.
Hmm.
And like he's got a lot of girls when it comes to hunting.
I got a lot of girls.
That's my only thing I'm going to actually,
like,
I'm not a bad hunter.
I'm definitely not a good honor.
But what I have going for me is all very good hunter goal for me is I like to
stick with it.
Yeah.
Well how could you possibly say you're not a good hunter?
Cause sometimes I go out with guys who were just so good,
just split good.
But are they good at a specific type of hunting?
They get really good.
You're a broad spectrum guide and Norma Jean,
I'm a good generalist.
But then I'll go out with guys who just know their stuff,
man,
you know,
and uh,
and it's a little bit,
it's almost a little bit shocking when I'm with someone who really knows what
they're doing and it,
it just,
yeah,
well doesn't that make sense to them?
If you,
if you go on doing that with a guy who only hunts mule deer in Utah and this guy
just patterns meal deer every year,
he knows all the trails.
He spends time in the spring,
like searching for them.
He spots them.
It keeps an eye on them.
He's watching them,
he's getting ready for the season to open up.
I mean,
that guy is obviously going to have a greater database of information about mule
deer than a guy.
Like you just got back from Bolivia eat and a monkey,
and then you,
you know,
you arrive in a,
you did eat a monkey.
Yeah.
I want to talk to you about that too.
That was a,
that was a crazy fucking episode.
Um,
it has a fascinating episode two,
because you're talking about like ancient stuff in ancient methods and,
and did the difference between people that are eating or existing primarily just
they're so assisting Hein.
I mean,
they're not,
there's no sport involved in what they're doing at all.
They're just trying to survive.
Yeah,
man,
they,
they loved the,
well,
this was,
I want to point out real quick,
uh,
one guy that I,
one guy that I hung with,
it's just like good and you know,
on the Remi Oh wow.
Yeah,
Remy Warren's very like,
like I would,
you know,
I,
I don't use this word very often to describe hundreds.
He was what I would call a talented hunter,
the cast talent.
Like it's just,
he gets it,
you know?
Um,
so
we were down in Bolivia.
Haven't had we not,
I haven't been on your podcast talking about this.
I don't believe so.
I don't think you've been on the podcast since he got back from Bolivia.
Have you?
I don't think I made it.
I don't think so.
So we were down in Bolivia.
We went down there to go up a river like a,
sorry river with these,
uh,
and travel with the Chimani,
which is an autonomous indigenous group in Bolivia.
Um,
you might know a way to approach thinking about it.
Where do you think about the reservation system that we have here in the u s
where there's,
you know,
a fair bit of autonomy on reservations.
Like they might be able to have a casino,
you know,
all this stuff that violates state law because they're,
they're uh,
you know,
like I was sort of a nation within a nation and Bolivia had these huge areas of
jungle,
um,
that are autonomous zones and we were in like the Trimont area,
so they are self governing.
Um,
we went and traveled up a,
a revenue stream,
like a basic river trip.
At the surface level.
We're going down there to fish a type of fish called [inaudible].
But the main thing I was interested in was just traveling with and,
and hunting with these guys.
And they hunt with bows for the most part.
Firearms are starting to come into their area,
but they hunt fish with Bose,
homemade boats.
Um,
and they hunt birds with bows and they do some big game hunting with bows,
but there,
but 90% of their protein comes out of the river in the form of fish and they
poisoned fish with a plant.
So we went out,
we went into a village and they were,
they were cultivating one of these plants.
There's a handful of plants down there and does it like we use a fish poison
here in the u s when we're trying to get rid of invasives or whatever called
wrote,
wrote is a root is derived from a root of a South American plant.
And,
uh,
these guys had leaf,
they had a tree that bar just like a green waxy leaf and you'd pound that into a
pulp and you'd go out and they'd go out and do a river and they've tried to find
a little channel,
like an isolated channel,
a river pool that doesn't have a lot of current coming into it.
And they'll pull up that plant and put it into a woven bag and just go out in
the water and stir the pulped up leaves in there.
And pretty soon all the fish come up in the Fisher suffocating.
It somehow affects efficiency,
ability to pull oxygen from the water.
So the fish come up and they're gasping for air at the surface and then they
just shoot the fish of their bows.
Um,
they do some netting for fish,
but most of its bow hunt.
And I fell in with a couple older guys there and we did some hunting and one of
these guys had only ever hunted with a bow,
but a year earlier he'd gone into some town in,
somehow got a Russian made 16 gauge single shot shotgun.
Um,
that was on,
it was held together with wire.
I was nervous about being around him when this is going on and they like to hunt
at night because now they have flashlights.
So they got flashlights and they got a shotgun and they got their bows and we
would,
they would wait until dusk and then we would head off into the jungle.
And these guys,
only s uh,
they speak their native language,
they know teeny bit of Spanish but they speak Chimani.
I would go out with them and I would have no idea what they're talking about and
we would leave at dusk and just go into the jungle and the noise of the jungle
at night just deafening if you never experienced,
I mean it's like,
it's the point where,
I mean have you ever been out in a windy area for long time?
We start to feel like it's like affecting your sanity or affecting your ability
to think clearly.
You know,
or worn around like small aircraft,
that engine noise.
You don't realize how agitated it's making UNT.
You get away from it and you'll all sudden,
it feels like the relaxing in some way.
The noise of the jungles so loud,
it's almost like that at night with the bugs and stuff going off and we go out
into the jungle and uh,
I knew from going into it that their favorite food,
even though they drive 90% of their protein from the river,
their favorite food is a spider monkey and their second favorite foods,
howler monkey.
And before it even gets dark out,
we go down this trail for a while through the jungle and they come to a date
tree and dates we'll fruit periodically throughout the year and you know,
you're close,
you're getting closer to the equator now they're sold.
There's not like you don't have the seasonality as much.
So plants or fruit all the time rather than just in the summertime and they get
to this date Trina's date,
trees fruiting and he's looking at these dates on the ground and he finds some
shit that on now realize most have been monkey shit and they got real interested
in what was going on up above us.
And pretty soon he sees a,
this howler monkey starts going through the tree tops and he shoots it down out
of the tree with a,
with that shotgun he had with him.
And first thing he does is he takes the tail because the tail off the monkey,
the tip of the Monkey's tail and buries it in the ground.
I couldn't even ask him why he was doing his blade or I learned it's you do
that.
So the next monkey you kill,
he doesn't get hung up in the tree buys tail.
Then just like a belief,
you know,
then he cuts some bark off a tree and makes little harness so he can carry the
monkey over his,
across his chest.
So He's just got the monkey slung on him like a baby carrier.
And uh,
we just had often in the jungle and hunt for several hours at night.
And then the next day when we got back and they gutted the monkey out and kept
all the intestines and everything out of that monkey.
And eventually they burned the hair off it and trust it like how you'd trust a
Turkey and smoked it over a fire and I did not want to eat a monkey.
Like it did not want to eat a primate,
you know?
But that point I'd been out with them and you know I was going to eat it.
It was very difficult for me to enjoy psychologically.
I had the same problem being in Vietnam and being served domestic dog where I
ate I domestic dog seven nights in a row and just was ne people go there.
What did it taste like?
I was like,
I can't even tell you.
It was like something I would get so hot like my body would feel so hot eaten
that just like,
it's like just this like wrongness we'll see is like because of nerves.
Yeah man.
I couldn't tell what it tastes like.
Logical.
He,
yeah,
very hard.
Eat the monkey.
If I could say what it tastes like eating that monkey.
It tasted like if you took steel cable and put liquid smoke on it,
they loved it.
Why do they,
what will they have a specific preference?
They like howler over spider,
a spider over Howard.
Would you like spiders now why a couple nights later we're coming back from
fishing one night and we had,
we had a giant catfish with us and a handful of other fish with us and we're
coming back to the jungle.
It's just getting,
starting to come on to darkness and they see another kind of monkey.
Oh,
I came here like Poo j or PJ or some,
what they call it in their language,
but a another kind of monkey and I'm like,
surely they're gonna go after this monkey.
No interest net monkey,
not a good one.
The same night they got the red howler monkey,
we go down the trail and it's just getting dark and I see a possum.
Same Marsupial oh saint possibly we have here and I'm like,
surely these guys are going to want that.
If Bailey to damn monkey,
they're going to want a possum.
People in the u s e possums,
they look at that thing in his walk by like it doesn't even exist.
And later I was able to ask them through like by asking them,
by asking someone who speaks some Spanish,
he was able to,
so it was like a threeway translation.
I was like,
why didn't you guys want the possum?
And he explained to me that you'd only eat a possum if you were real hungry.
But meanwhile thereafter monkey and when they get a monkey,
it's a party.
A party.
Yeah.
Everybody comes in,
they're real excited and a thing I say in the show,
we did a whole three part series about Bolivia and the Chimani.
But
the thing I say in the show when we're talking about this is think of th th
there's only two things I know about that that get the kind of enthusiasm from a
culinary perspective in the u s to get the kind of enthusiasm needed guys had
from monkeys.
It'd be someone who has homegrown tomatoes in Morel.
Mushrooms are the only things I know about that people have that level of love
for it.
They were more excited about eating that red howler monkey than you've ever been
about eating anything you ever ate.
I promise you.
And they eat him on a regular basis?
No,
no,
they hadn't gotten,
they had,
they rarely go up to this area.
And that's one of the reasons I like to go up to this areas cause you can get
monkeys.
They hadn't had a monkey for eight months I think I remember,
I think it was eight months.
They had had those last time they had gone into an area where they would,
where they would find the Monkees.
So did you specifically ask them to go to this area where the monkeys were or
was it just weird?
Is going into an area that's like the happy hunting grounds.
Why?
Lot of fee.
They were very excited to go and it was several days up river.
It's like apocalypse now.
They're very excited to go up.
Does Eric Cyr they like to go to,
to hunt and fish.
So this,
so this monkey thing tastes like steel cable.
Like it was just chilling.
The smoked Turkey drumstick?
Yes.
Okay.
Imagine the lowest part on that smokey Turkey drumstick where you're getting
close to the joint.
Just pulling it off.
That's what that money is there.
But I'll tell you something.
It's like,
well,
they had a baby monkey at one point.
Okay.
A very young baby monkey at one point and they just cooked it in a walk and I
wasn't even offered any of that.
It just save that for themselves.
Couple of the guys had it.
I remember one of them had a like a head in the bowl loaning.
Jeez.
It was funny.
Bodies to dude.
It was funny about it is I remember being in a,
I've ever,
no,
I did,
I hunted with another like an indigenous group and in a Guyana and uh,
I remember this guy had a shirt with Muhammad Ali on it and um,
I was trying to ask him about it.
He didn't,
he had no idea.
And another one,
I had a shirt from a pizza place.
He had no idea what pizza was.
Not the day you have a responsibility to know about Muhammad,
I'll eat pizza.
But just saying like,
for them to hear that,
for them to hear from us,
be like,
dude,
it is very rare to eat a monkey.
You know,
it was just to them,
it was just baffling.
It was like they weren't like,
yeah I know some people don't like it.
You know,
like if you go down and someone gives you squirrel brains are like,
yeah man,
it's kind of fucked up.
We eat squirrel brains.
Like no it was just in their mind I was like their fathers,
grandfathers,
great grandfathers,
great,
great grandfather's like howler monkey.
How would you not be excited about this?
W they no idea of it being like globally fringe.
It's just so strange that we don't have their language available.
So it's a,
you can't have like a real conversation about it.
Like what is it about this that you enjoy more?
Cause you guys shot a deer too,
but they wanted the monkey more than the deal.
They liked the deer more than a monkey net.
Dear was phenomenal.
They want the deer more than them.
I don't really like the monkey more than,
than the deer.
Deer was very good.
They were very glad about the deer.
But they like the monkey more than the deer.
What do they think about your bow?
Cause you,
you,
they're blown away.
They were blown away by compound bow I had,
did you feel like you wanted to leave it with them?
You know,
but if you did they wouldn't be able to get arrows for it anyway.
Yeah,
there's that and like you have all these weird,
uh,
hanging out with people,
like with people who like that you have all of these weird hangups or at least I
do like all this like colonial type guilt or something where you don't want to,
I'll put it to you this way.
I was bummed that that guy had that shotgun.
Really?
He's glad as hell.
Right?
It's the greatest thing that ever happened to him.
He's Damn Shotgun,
right?
He couldn't be happier.
But I was like,
man,
you know,
I just wish you didn't have that shotgun.
You start to hunt with your bow.
So it's like me,
you're,
you're exercising some kind of weird,
I don't want to call it like races.
It's not racism.
It's something,
it's just like some kind of like the new colonial is a puritan aspect of it or
pure,
pure.
Like,
for instance,
there's these guys down there,
there's these Bolivians who are from the urban area down there like of your,
like a of mixed European indigenous ancestry and theirs,
they're very,
like in Bolivia,
the ruling class,
the urban people are very different than,
than,
than the indigenous people.
Okay.
There is,
they have it,
I don't want to say categorically,
but there's a view of the indigenous people that would've seen more like the
1870 [inaudible] here in the u s in some circles.
The way they view the backwardness of the indigenous people and trying to bring
out missionaries to,
you know,
help them find religion and get them to settle down and stop being nomadic.
And you know,
there's all this kind of stuff that we were having that conversation 150 years
ago here.
Um,
there's these guys who are doing these trips.
So who we orchestrated our trip through who are trying to introduce these guys
[inaudible] they're trying to get these guys hip to the idea of not eaten one of
their favorite fish,
which is the Durado because rich white guys will pay a lot of money to come down
and catch Durado.
That was kind of our end to go down here was to go up to this area where they
catch Durado.
So they're trying to sell these dudes on not messing with Dorado.
I was bummed out about that.
Like I hated seeing that because that's her favorite fish,
man.
Will you tell?
You're trying to tell them that like now we want to tell them that not eat their
favorite fish because guys like me,
you might want to come down and catch the thing and it's not even going to have
a negative implication ramification anyway,
so you're not going to over harvest them with bows and arrows,
you know?
Right.
But it's just like this weird thing.
So yeah,
I didn't like it.
The guy had the shotgun,
even though he was glad about the shotgun.
I had my boat when I brought my bow down,
that my main goal and having a bow,
yeah,
you're not going to get a firearm down there.
Like they can't have firearms,
not supposed to have firearms.
So I was gonna bring a firearm.
I would never be able to get it in there anyways.
It'd probably been very bad to bring it.
Um,
but I could bring a bow,
no problem.
My main goal in bringing the bowl was it,
I would have like some,
uh,
that I would establish some credibility with them.
And it did.
When I,
we got up and I was shooting their bowls and doing some fishing with their
equipment and stuff.
When I got out my bow,
they were like,
yeah,
very,
very surprised by a compound bow.
When you see how fast the Arrow shoot,
they couldn't believe it.
They,
a lot of them wouldn't,
they didn't want to shoot at someone wants,
shoot it.
A lot of them are like,
just deeply that out.
I'm not impressing me,
but was impressed by the technology.
Did you let them shoot it?
Yeah,
let a couple of them shooting wrist release.
Oh.
But it was just like they'd,
you know,
it's hard to keep them from dry firing.
I mean she's like,
cause you can't tell like I can't explain to,
right.
So you're trying to demonstrate things.
Those someone was going to get hurt shooting the boat.
Right.
And these weren't like,
and you know what's funny is these guys that beat my ass all over town,
a lot of them couldn't come close to pulling the bow back.
That's how heavy is the ball.
70 they couldn't pull it back.
No.
Cause it's,
you develop a muscle for pulling those bolts back and he's the guy that beat my
ass.
They couldn't believe how hard that bowl was pulled back.
And I just wanted to be like,
it's just,
I just can pull,
cause I pulled bows,
you know?
Hmm.
It's hard.
Yeah.
It's like they had a,
I'm sure if they had to spend a day at it,
they would have gotten the pull down.
But just different.
They're like going about it.
How they pulled their longbows.
Right.
It's just a different kind of thing.
You know,
you have their bows didn't seem very strong.
No,
not at all.
Not at all.
So it's just about,
and they had really long arrows to which is super long arrows and they would
carry three kinds of tips.
They carry a big game tip of bird tip and a fish tips.
So every guy's got three arrows with his bow,
but they love that bow.
But I wound up being,
I just really wanted to be able to hang out with them and have them not like
stop.
Like when I would walk up into them where they,
they'd be standing around eating some fish around their fire and I would walk up
and then I'll quit eating and I eventually got what we are comfortable together.
Like they would kind of show me stuff and they kind of,
you know,
I don't want to say they liked me,
but they just said sort of accepted me and I eventually got it splain to them
through actions and otherwise that I was very interested in their food.
I was very interested in the holiday haunted.
I would go out into the jungle at night with them.
Know,
I got stung by a bullet ant and you know,
and that's excruciating.
And they watch me kind of like software through that and come out of that.
And eventually we became friendly,
you know,
and I had the bow or just so,
cause I wanted to go out and hunt with them and because I had the bowl,
they were impressed by the bowl and it was just better.
It just worked better.
Me having a bow.
So they took you in?
Yeah.
Once they saw that they were like,
yeah,
they felt that um,
you pulled your weight.
Yeah.
They want to kind of like an like,
you know,
and the guys that we were traveling with those down there with uh,
Yannis was there,
Dan was there and a guy named Phil was down there,
camera operator named Phil was down there and we all want to be in like cool
with these guys,
you know,
like we got along well,
but it took a long,
it took a long time to get kind of in with him and have him start sort of
showing you their world a little bit because you,
you realize that they're used to being viewed there.
There had been enough exposure to outside to the outside world to realize that
the outside world usually carried a certain amount of disapproval for their food
and dress and other things.
I gathered that was my impression,
but after awhile they were like,
oh,
this guy's cool.
You know,
when we would just hang out.
Did you guys have to pay them?
Like how did they accept you into their fee paid the guys,
these guys are trying to develop a recreational fishery in this area,
but they're going into places.
No one goes into and they're trying to establish,
they were in the process of trying to establish a thing where they would have
paying clients come down and the paying clients would go on these river trips,
stop to fish in these areas.
The only way you can do it because it's Chimani land,
the only way you can do is by going through the Chimani and the only people
you're going to hire [inaudible] to get the boats up the rivers and paddle the
bolts and run the bolts and run the engines and get them stuck out of the wrap.
It's an all the difficult traveling that involves,
you'd hire Chimani guys to do it.
So we hired the guys that hire the Chimani with the sole goal of,
I was just interested in traveling with the [inaudible].
How did you get this in your head?
Like what was it something you researched in advance mean how does,
how do you make a decision to go to one particular indigenous tribe?
Because I did a similar thing.
Um,
I did a similar thing for TV down in,
in Guyana was just blown away by it.
Just traveling with guys and the guys and Gals,
you know,
they were still actively hunting with bows in some ways.
They were a more modernized people,
but they were still avid bow.
Fishermen hunted with Bose.
I took my boat down there and haunted I,
I remember I was shadow of big game bird,
a big Turkey like game bird of a tree with my bow from about 40 yards and they
were blown away,
man.
Um,
it was just,
it's like fun.
I learned more about hunting and about looking at the landscape and about
indigenous food paths in those weeks that I've been fortunate to do that kind of
trip then.
Then I would learn in years of hunting with American hunters because you gotta
understand these guys don't,
or let's say you're with someone who's,
who's 35 years old,
40 years old.
He's haunted
probably five,
six days a week for his entire life within a hundred mile radius of his home.
The level of understanding that you get,
but it's,
but it's raw jungle,
you know,
it's like undeveloped jungle.
The level of understanding you get about what's going on around you.
It's just different than what we're able to achieve today.
Especially someone like me who try,
I travel around a lot and experienced a lot of different things,
but what I,
what I lack,
what I miss out on from the way I do things that I missed out on that level of
detailed,
local understanding that I had as a kid.
For instance,
for the lake where I grew up,
like I grew up on a newer,
well,
right,
better than anybody or as good as anybody.
Um,
they have that about the jungle.
So to go out with guys like that and just watch how they interact and what noise
make sense to them,
um,
you know,
it's just,
it's really informative and it just helps you kind of understand humanity
better.
I remember going out in the jungle with them one night and it's Meryl Summit,
hold loud it that you can't even
believe how loud it is and all these noises.
You're like,
what does all this stuff?
It must be whatever.
And then I,
one time I hear a noise.
It sounds like this often the jungle,
everything,
they just stopped.
I was like,
oh,
so that noise of the thousands of noises going on,
this is very interesting to them,
you know?
And what was it?
I have no idea.
They didn't go after it.
They just know they were real interested in that.
I was like,
something made that noise and they're like,
of all the sticks snapping and things dropping and birds going off and insects,
you know,
getting bit by bullet ants.
They hear what sounds like a stick way the hell off.
And it just means something to them was the bullet.
And as bad as everybody says it is dude.
Yeah.
You ever see that Schmidt pain index?
Yes.
The Schmidt pain index,
he scores all insect bites and the bull ants,
the only one that gets a four plus rating like a five star hotel.
It's the highest rated.
There's,
he has found.
And he's uh,
he studies,
you know,
insect toxins and insect stings.
He's found nothing else.
It's as painful to was,
it feels like,
it feels at first like you got zapped by a wasp and Hornet.
Um,
and maybe 10 minutes into it,
a minute into it,
it becomes something very different than that.
10 minutes into it you feel like something's really wrong,
like arthritic pain,
throbbing,
throbbing pain that goes way away from the source and we couldn't speak and
we're out in the jungle at night and first they go and find a vine and pulp up
some of the vine and put the vine.
And where I got hit,
I don't know what the Viola had,
I couldn't tell that it had any difference than mean anything different.
But I was bit on my ankle and one of the camera guy,
Phil buried but was bid out in hand at the same time.
And he kept pointing to Phil's hand,
but then running his finger,
the Chimani guys pointing to Phil's hand and running his finger up his arm,
like to his heart.
He keeps doing that to Phil and he keeps taking me and pointed his finger to his
ankle and then a running his finger up the inside of his leg to his groin.
And I thought that means that the top poison or toxin or somehow it's going to
travel up and get you.
I couldn't tell what he was talking about and all I knew was as bad to get bit
by a bullet ant prison.
So back when even we weren't even able to walk,
I wasn't on that walk.
I just had to lay there and just like rive,
you know how long,
well I'll tell you this an hour and 45 minutes later I couldn't remember what
the hell ankle,
it was really no mark,
no mark and you couldn't figure out which ankle I was walking under.
Two hours later I remember thinking like I've ever realized that I couldn't
think of what ankle it had been on.
Do you think that's because the medication that they use because of the plants?
I've read that from a lot of other people really?
Well I thought it lasted for like 24 hours
for me.
Now they do a thing where they take like a,
some kind of Mitt and fill it full of them and you put the mid on,
it's like an initiation and you get bid a lot and then it's a whole,
I guess it's a whole other world,
but for me,
I think that was,
I could be wrong.
No,
I don't think I am man.
I think that it was,
the peak was 30,
40 minutes into it.
Okay.
Um,
and in then it just taper,
taper,
taper and then gone.
Now if I got hit by one now,
knowing what I know now,
I don't want to say that I would enjoy it,
but I would be more interested.
I would be interested in what was going on and watching the progression.
But I was so scared because I didn't know what it meant.
I didn't know if it was like getting hit by a rattlesnake right.
Where you need to go and figure shit out or what.
And they weren't able to tell me
what was
weird.
Yeah.
What I later learned,
what they were saying was make sure that you don't have any in your sleeves and
make sure you don't have any,
because they'll come up and get you on the chest,
which might be bad or don't get you on the balls,
which is bad.
Oh yeah,
I would imagine so.
He's saying like,
not that it's traveling up to,
you're not that it's traveling up to your grind,
but that ain't,
don't let it get up your pants and get you the Schmidt.
Oh,
there's the Schmidt pain index.
300 Mil Lens.
300 minutes.
Okay.
Wow.
But he's really soup that index up.
Recently I got,
I got stung by a wasp recently in Colorado and it was the most fucking painful
staying I've ever felt in my life.
And I don't know what happened.
I was walking and then all of a sudden I go,
ah,
like it was like unusual.
It didn't make any sense.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Just bit me.
Like I've been stung by bees before.
Yeah,
I don't,
I think I've been stung by Hornets.
I,
I think it was a wasp,
it was a wasp or a hornet.
I didn't even see what the bug was because it was going through this heavy Bush
and,
uh,
my fucking arm swollen,
like Popeye,
it was so weird.
Like it was hard,
like the bottom of my forum turned right.
Bam.
Got Hit by something like that down in Virginia that the next day turned into a
big hard knob.
Like he had like a softball stuck unders.
Yeah.
And it lasted for like five or six days and it was,
it was so itchy.
Like I had to do everything I could to keep from clawing my arm apart where I
would go under the shower and I turned the shower up really hot to the point
where it'd be painful with any other part of my body and just shove that arm
underneath the super hot water.
Like it was scratching it with this insanely hot water.
Yeah.
It was burning my arm.
But,
uh,
nothing like a bullet that I got hit by a lionfish.
Oh.
I've seen those things in that,
um,
again,
scare the shit out of me because I didn't really know what all it meant.
We were spearfishing and I hit by a lion fish and the thing you do is you heat
water up
yeah.
To boiling and let it cool.
And the minute you can even kind of stand to put your,
watch your hand in there,
you dip your hand in there and it takes the pain away.
Wow.
That wasn't,
that wasn't their thing.
It's just like my hand swelled up like,
like,
like not really usable like an old Mickey mouse hand for how long?
A couple hours again.
We were out.
I had gone down,
we were spear fishing in The Bahamas and I had gone down and a shot a lion fish
cause they're good to eat.
Um,
I mean we were doing like [inaudible],
they're very good,
really white flesh yet you gotta be real careful with them.
I'd gone down and shot a lion fish.
What's that?
Hey,
careful house.
So you have to avoid the status of what we would do is when you get a lion fish,
we'd take the lionfish and leave it on the spear and an open cooler up and stick
the spear and lionfish into the cooler and shut the lid and Paul so that your
spirit would come out and the lion fish would fall into the coop.
Now lionfish,
just uh,
for your listeners,
it's a,
it's a non native that,
uh,
has been introduced into the Caribbean is wreaking much habit from Florida
southward and they're there.
They're doing a lot to try to get rid of him.
You see,
waxes are so viciously territorial and out there in The Bahamas you have these
small little coral heads and a couple of lionfish and move in there and they
would just move out other fish.
So there's no regulations on line,
but you're allowed to kill as many as you want.
They encourage you to kill.
The manager wants to,
will the people let them loose from acquiring them?
Yeah,
I think it's somehow they escaped through the aquarium trade as an aquarium.
Yeah.
Man,
I can't,
I don't want to say for sure.
Maybe you're a,
you're a internet whiz over here.
Jamie will bill tell you the answer to that,
but uh,
how they,
how they got in the first place.
But anyhow,
then later would take poultry shears and just get big rubber gloves,
wants to fish is dead and take poultry shears and cut all the thorns off it.
Then fly it.
So the thorns are where the toxins stored,
not in the glands.
They got injected in you with the,
with the,
with the thorns.
These are the spines,
you know?
Right.
And these spines,
is the toxin in the spine itself or is there a Glam on a Nathan on it?
Yeah,
that's my understanding now.
I'd gone,
I ran out of breath and left my spear,
stuck in a lionfish down on the bottom,
came up,
got a breath,
went down and as I'm trying to get my lion fish out of this air using without
pulling him off spearhead,
notice the grouper and in a hole.
So I went up and I got a lion fish on my spear and I'm waving to my brother to
come over because I don't want,
I can't take the lion fish off my spirit.
I'm wavering him to come over about the grouper and he comes over and he's got a
snap or on the end of his spear.
So I take the snap or off his spear and I'm holding
the damn snapper in my right hand and I have a lion fish on my spear and my left
hand and I'm going under water trying to point to the hole that has the group
are in it and somehow swung that lionfish into my hand and it got all weird and
puffy and I crawled up into the boat and it was just kinda like riding in the
bottom of the boat.
And I started getting really scared because my hand started,
feel hot and all bloated.
And uh,
eventually wave my brother and our buddy Eric over.
And we went in and we were at 45 minutes from the shore and went in.
And by then I was really scared.
And my buddy Ronnie Bain was there and he's like saying I should put it under
cold water.
And I went and typed in the internet.
It's like,
do not put it in cold water
through the,
it was so
[inaudible] you have here it goes speculated,
the root of the problem was only six lionfish accidentally released from an
acquirement aquarium during the hurricane Andrew in 1992.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Genetic research supports this finger pointing,
but it's likely many more have been intentionally released by retired aquarium
enthusiasts.
We're tired.
Aquarium enthusiasts.
That's a funny way of looking at it.
But Florida has a gigantic issue with invasive species mean it comes from
aquarium.
It's amazing.
Oh there it's pythons are,
you know,
they found Nial crocs in the town.
Yeah,
Dave.
Uh,
there was a reading a whole article how they have just to kill onsite for Nial
crocs.
They're just terrified.
These fucking giant Crocs gonna grow to be these 28 foot long killers like they
have in Mozambique or wherever the fuck it is.
Florida is the Florida is the future of wilderness.
How so?
Because as we move species around
with reckless abandon,
mmm.
Intentionally or unintentionally,
and we eliminate biodiversity in some areas to habitat destruction.
And if current trends continue in,
the earth continues to get hotter and we lose a lot of the climatic diversity,
different climates that we have different places.
If that continues,
um,
I think that you will have,
we'll continue to see like the great mixing,
you know,
uh,
and you and we'll just wind up with a situation where there are certain,
every animal is going to get a shot at every biome and you're just going to have
it be that certain ones that can thrive are going to thrive and you're not going
to have the levels of endemism that we have now.
And I think that,
yeah,
in the future,
you know,
just look at what the wild pig has managed to do here in the u s you know,
it's the dominant large animal on some landscapes.
So it's a non native,
um,
the,
in my lifetime,
in the Great Lakes,
the round gobys zebra muscles,
if you go now and drop a baited hook down in places that I grew up fishing,
the first thing you would pull up as a Gobi,
they were not there.
It just certain things are winners and certain things are losers.
Not all the winners are going to be non natives because whitetail deer do well
around people.
Crows seem to do well around people.
Canada geese do very well around people.
It just got to be that.
It's just going to be more and more and more aquarium.
Like isn't it weird how
people have this desire to manipulate and manage all the other wildlife?
I mean it is strange when you think about the evidence points to the contrary.
The evidence points to,
I mean there,
there are like,
like you said,
more whitetail deer in the United States now that when Columbus landed,
so they've done a great job and,
and bringing back healthy populations to certain animals.
But then he seemed like the shit they've done in Florida where the pythons are
fucking eating alligators.
I mean if you,
you've seen that image of them,
that's a famous image that is a crazy image of 20 foot long python,
that eight a fucking alligator.
I mean they have this crazy system going on down there where these non
indigenous animals are just crushing all these other animals and,
and surviving and thriving in an environment that's pretty compatible for them.
You know,
as far as you know,
tropical hot climate,
moist,
plenty of things to eat,
plenty of life out there for them to snuff out
in some areas.
They're finding a friend of mine,
Robert Abernathy,
who was a biologist and in conservationist,
big hunter,
he,
uh,
he was working with some guys that are going down there and there's a whole
class of mid size animal that's just missing from those python areas now.
Whoa.
Based like Possum,
raccoon sized critters are just gone.
You know,
you will see like,
that's why I was bring us full circle back to some things we were talking about.
A lot of the conservation groups that I get involved in.
Um,
things like,
you know,
National Wild Turkey Federation,
Rocky Mountain Elk Foundation,
um,
they pick,
you know,
they're,
they're powered by hunters and powered by hunter money in the,
in the effort to preserve habitat for certain species.
But like native animals that wind up by helping knows,
you know,
you're helping all other creatures because you can't fix out.
Like if you fix elk habitat,
you're fixing everyone's habitat.
You know,
it's like a keystone thing.
You,
if you help elk by salvaging riparian areas,
you're helping all creditors across the board.
You know,
you're in enhancing wildlife and a big that you have.
And then if you look at native wildlife and you cherish native wildlife,
and I do one of the big risks we have coming down lines,
just the non native stuff,
you know,
I mean as far as even just vegetation,
we have a lot of areas that we're seeing the,
those high quality plants being displaced by plants that make native wildlife
sick that they can't live on.
It's a big,
big problem in a and in,
in some ways.
You want to look at Florida and it's almost like the wildlife situation in
Florida is almost kind of become a joke where it's so outlandish.
It's like this like Jurassic Park Environment.
Yeah.
But same time it's also,
you look at it like God,
you know,
it's like this wild place and it's,
it's the new wilderness in some ways,
but in some ways just like it's really sad what that's gonna mean for the
endemics.
Well,
Florida sort of attracts that even with human beings though.
I mean those are non native human beings that went down there and took over too.
It's all people that escaped from the mob,
from New York and weird people from Cuba that came up and rabbits of like Carl
Hiaasen man.
And then the cocaine thing.
That's also a non native plant.
It's,
you know,
it's main biproduct introduced to that area that changed the entire ecosystem
financially.
You know,
there's more banks per capita in Miami,
then there are the rest of the country.
And the reason being is because that's where they fucking laundered money.
I mean,
it's really clear.
I grew up with just tremendous
Findlay for Florida because in Michigan that's in my area,
Michigan,
like when you went on vacation,
you went to Florida just like you didn't go.
It was just where you want a place to vacation.
Yeah.
But now we're like,
man,
all other parts of the country,
people are like,
you went where?
I'm like,
yeah man,
Florida.
Why like cousins Florida?
Man,
it's amazing.
You know?
It was a great fishing,
but a lot of people.
But yeah,
it's just like we
so strongly with Florida and the fishing in Florida that I do,
I have a soft spot and I was down there and I was talking to this kid who likes
to hunt down there not long ago.
And he was telling me this is the hunting and fishing capital of the world,
Florida.
Yeah.
Well they have a lot of game down there.
He was,
he was a wild pig owner.
Lot of wild pigs,
right?
Yup.
Isn't that where you shot the wild pig with the Bryant Gumbel in that episode?
Yeah,
it Florida's a nutty spot.
And you know,
they're saying that it's not even going to be there if the water rises the way
it's rising right now,
they're thinking Miami won't even exist in 30 or 40 years.
That because it's all like very porous,
porous limestone.
Yeah.
That the is just,
it's not going to be like New Orleans where they get damn it up.
It's like,
it's just going to come right through the ground and that's going to be a wrap.
It's going to be more,
uh,
there's a thing I like to fish called flats.
It's going to be a lot more flat.
You get to be flat near the Miami Needy,
needy water has trained you to be like a lot of red fish or taking a fucking
boat ride for fish around the Miami hotel.
What time is your flight?
But telling me I gotta get,
I gotta get going right now.
Oh,
I got it.
I think that he was saying that'd be stupid.
Leave after three 30.
Okay,
well it's three 13.
Don't be stupid.
We'll get you,
get you out of here in a few minutes.
Um,
what else did I want to ask you about?
Oh the,
the,
one of the things about Bolivia that I found fascinating was that the people
seem to have adapted physically to that environment.
Like you were saying that you were traveling with those people and they didn't
sweat.
Yeah.
Like you're sweating like crazy.
It's porn on your pores.
We would go out at night and uh,
well first off these guys chew a coca leaves.
Ah Rich.
We all got into big time.
I could ever tell what it's actually doing it,
you know,
it's like it's what they make cocaine from it.
They take the coca leaf and they put a lime on it.
It was a liar.
No baking soda that's they put on their lives.
That's what they use of that Betel nut.
No,
they take a leaf and you pack your cheek.
They call it bowl a ball.
I mean to the point where your cheek looks seriously puffed out and flame what
full of leaves and then you put baking soda in there cause it's somehow
activates the alkaloids and is supposed to give you a boost and keep you going.
At night.
So I'd be out there and I have a couple of water bottles and I just be slam
water and just pouring sweat and I'm not like a sweaty dude,
but I'd be sweating so bad out in the jungle drinking all this water and these
guys each got a bag.
They were these little shoulder,
it looks almost like a woman's purse but it's like a handmade bag they carry and
it would have kitchen knife in it like a paring knife,
which should be their hunting.
I,
I've or they just have that in their back pocket.
They don't wear shoes that had that bag.
They don't want to shoot.
Yeah.
You know what one of the guys put shoes on,
we're going out and he couldn't get to him cause he never wore shoes but he
wanted to try them out.
They go out barefoot so,
and they got this leave their cocoa leaves,
they got a bag of baking soda and then they had this like one of these water
bottles and I thought that they were somehow able to get through all night,
two of them with one water bottle of water.
And I was impressed by that.
But later someone told me it's a,
it's the distilled spirit.
So it's not even water.
No,
it's like vodka,
but not so the drinking vodka and hydrate.
Yeah.
Chewing cocoa leaves.
Drinking.
It's not vodka,
but it's like a,
it's like a rice.
It's like a,
like,
uh,
some kind of thing.
Like you take rice,
wine and some out to steal it.
I don't understand how they did it.
Wow.
The guys I was with,
remember what it was and he goes real strong and uh,
like a moonshine almost.
Yeah.
And they would be out there with a mouth pack full of coca leaves,
sticking baking soda in there,
drinking and stuff.
I have a water bottle and they wouldn't drink water all night.
Wow.
I was dying.
Yeah.
They're accustomed to it.
But here's the thing,
when you want to get into that,
if you took those boys,
because they've never experienced,
they've never experienced it.
It's a temperature below 40 degrees Fahrenheit,
you know,
in life.
Right.
So if you took those boys and I was like,
hey man,
we're going to go hunt in the Arctic for Caribou and is going to be snow on the
ground,
you know,
um,
they would go home and talk about how we are some kind of superman.
He rose
sleeping out in the snow,
you know,
blow their mind,
what have you,
took them to new Novak and they'd blow their mind.
Took him to that.
You just get really like you get set in year.
Remember how everybody always likes to make that big deal about how in the,
like in the NC Witt language,
they have like 24 words for snow.
All right.
I just don't think that we have a difficult time describing people who liked to
ski,
have many ways of describing snow.
It's kind of a,
it's like a little bit is it's almost dishonest.
So we have like,
yeah,
we have like light powder,
heavy powder,
slushy snow,
you know,
on and on and on.
Like we have ways of describing snow and it's easy to sort of mythologize um,
people or you go down,
you get the feeling that there's like these super,
I do that these superhuman beings,
but then,
you know,
I look at it,
she's like,
they're just used to a landscape that's baffling to me.
You know,
like,
look,
there's four of us out.
Two of US got hit by a bullet ants who got hit by bullet ants,
me and the other white guy.
Right.
Those guys need to hit by a bullet and they're barefoot.
Yeah.
How they,
why did they not get hit by a bullet ant?
Because they walked through.
They just know the risks the same way.
If I took them and we were walking around somewhere in some urban environment,
they might not know one,
it's a good time to cross the street and walk off the other side.
The other one,
you know,
it was,
I'd be like,
what are you dumb?
But no,
he just doesn't know.
I don't know.
Like I wasn't tuned into the threat of bullet ants.
They would notice snakes that I didn't,
you know,
they would see a snake.
They noticed that I,
that I didn't notice.
They would always,
when it got to a log,
they would inspect the log very carefully.
If I had a bull ant on it,
they would kill it very delicately with the tip of a bow.
But they just had a way that they'd like to like press and kill the bullet ant
and like it's very like dainty fashion.
Um,
why is that?
I don't know.
I have to figure it out man.
They just had like a little way that they would crush bullet ants.
It was interesting with bullet ants go in these large groups or maybe they
didn't want to disturb it cause a pheromones would get all of their bullet ants
excited.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if you got a bunch of Hornets round,
you start flailing wildly.
I don't know.
I would just notice that they would do it.
They just walked through and they knew their area and yeah,
I was tempted to be like,
man,
these are like gods.
They're so aware.
But then I feel like had I been brought up there,
hanging out,
I might've not got hit by ball.
I got hit by bullet.
Well,
they probably all been hit right.
I asked them and they couldn't.
I later was able to ask them and one guy was saying he had probably been hit,
maybe.
I remember,
I thought he'd said somehow round nine times.
And another guy was saying he had no way of recollecting how many times you've
been hit by a bullet down.
Wow.
That's crazy that they walk around barefoot.
Yeah.
They do things barefoot.
That or what did their feet look like?
Not like yours.
Just flattened out and they got him down and get rid of your feet.
Get Real,
flattened out your toe,
your thumb toe,
let's say,
starts to move away.
Like a monkey starts to move away from your other toes.
I never seen anything so like it quite as much as I was in the Philippines,
in the highlands.
And,
uh,
the guys there,
they're there in the mountain like in serious mountains,
barefoot.
You know,
growing up,
hunting their whole lives in the mountains,
barefoot on just bad rock and everything all the time and their feet.
You wouldn't have been able to put that foot in the shoe.
No way now.
Wow.
Their tolls had there told her soul spread.
You can find pictures of that stuff online.
She was like kind of like a famous sort of thing that happens to those guys and
the s in the central highlands and Luzon island,
their feet are just incredible.
But I think it's just like your feet,
your toes are held,
you know,
inside your shoes.
Your totals are held in the way that they just,
if you're walking on a rock and in mountainous landscapes all the time,
your feet just fan out.
Wow.
You know,
like hands.
Yeah,
man.
Like creepy,
creepy.
I don't want to see creepy in a bad way,
but creepy to you.
When I was there,
I spent more time looking at people's feet.
Then I did their faces just to try to figure it out.
And some of these old guys had these tattoos that recounted when they used to
head hunt for the Japanese after World War II.
Guys were,
you know,
they were pretty hardcore fellows because after,
when,
um,
when they took the Philippines,
somebody that Japanese went up and just hit out,
you know,
and it would make a big sport out of fining them.
Wow.
Because the Americans wanted them,
you know,
and they'd get these tattoos that are exploits.
We met old people and they were introduced to us as such,
but who'd been headhunters,
you know,
and they would have their tail narrate it on their thing and they would,
uh,
go out in the jungle and they had these souped up air rifles and they'd go out
in the jungle and hot air rifles.
And then they had these,
you have here electro shocking for fish.
Yeah.
They would have homemade electro shocking kits would have a car battery in a
bag.
Like I have saw us.
Got,
it.
Had a big huge detergent bottle that you turned into a backpack.
And in that detergent bottle he had a stack of batteries.
And you had a negative into positive wand and he would stand out on rocks and
the river we were doing,
we were floating down a river it these guys,
he's standing on a rock and the river and put those under,
put those ones under rocks and under logs,
electro shock and fish and shrimp,
freshwater shrimp.
And how was he grounded?
You just stand on a rock and stick them in their same way when you're electro
fishing for anything going to survey and he would shock them up.
Then run down river with a net and net up all the stuff that he's shocked and
he'd get a log burning and roll the log over and lay the shrimp and crabs on the
log until they turn red and eat them.
Wow.
My brother was shocking fishing one time and got done shock and fish for a fish
survey was walking back from having shocked fish and he had the fish in a gunny
sack and a bolt of lightning came out of the sky,
hit the ground next to him and his shot of that electricity shot up into the
sack of fish and shocked him.
Whoa.
I'd like to end on that because
some kind of cosmic retribution.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Holy Shit.
Well,
Remy got hit by lightening.
You know that story,
right?
[inaudible] got some good stories.
He's got some really good story.
He's got a story about that.
They were burning brush one time.
Someone burned a big brush pile and it was dry conditions and they burned a big
brush pile and all kinds of rodents started running out of the brush pile on
fire.
Starting little fires all over the place as they ran away.
Oh No,
it's a horrific story.
Oh my God.
Let's,
I want to end on that.
Well,
listen,
this book is fucking excellent.
Um,
the complete turn off the fade music.
Yes.
I forgot this thing.
I got to talk about seven more minutes.
Yeah.
This is important because,
uh,
if you have Verizon files,
Oh yes.
All your listeners.
Yeah.
Verizon files is in some kind of,
there was some kind of piss and match.
I don't really understand it,
but they've pulled for now they've pulled out door channel and sports from
channel off their lineup
and uh,
they're suggesting that you go and watch that.
They're like suggesting alternative content.
They're pointing people to like,
like,
like reality is shows that deal in hunting in some way.
It'd be like if you told people
that
you know,
the,
you are not going to call the UFC anymore.
Teenage mutant Ninja Turtle.
No.
Go Watch WWF.
Right.
It'd be like,
that's like
if you have variety,
if you use Verizon in any way,
shape or form,
do me a favor and a lot of it just do people a favor and um,
make sure to go and complain about that.
And what is this?
Because it's a contract contract dispute of some sort.
So the way it was explained to me was that there's some sort of an agenda to
push out outdoor programming.
You don't believe that's the case?
I don't know if that's true or not.
You think it's just a contract one,
the reason I do wonder.
Yeah,
if there's,
there's,
there's something I'd like that is,
it could be that,
you know,
it definitely came about,
it seems to have definitely come about at the time of the Cecil the lion deal
for sure.
They,
and they also said,
well it's low viewership,
but they carry networks that are lower viewership,
Al Jazeera or they carry a lot of networks that are lower.
Um,
I think with the ride,
I think it was some pressure.
It'll get pressure from viewers who I explain it,
they want the show of what the show was mean.
Um,
I think that if someone,
if they are making some kind of stand and it is like,
oh,
we don't approve a hunting,
I would say,
look at my show and ask yourself,
is my show a negative or a positive for wildlife and conservation?
I think the answer is pretty clear.
I would like to see them really change their mind about that.
And how do people get in touch?
There's,
there's a website right there is a website also.
Just go and let,
if you use any kind of Verizon product,
man,
your phone.
I use Verizon for my phone and I've definitely let them know.
Um,
yeah I do as well.
I hope people can get in there and demand access back.
Yeah.
I'm trying to find the website cause I think it was explained to me.
Did someone send it to me?
You know,
you can all change and here it is right here.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
you can also store it.
Here it is.
I'm sorry.
No,
keep,
keep my outdoor tv.com.
So go to keep my outdoor tv.com one word,
t v t the letter t letter V,
keep my outdoor tv.com and a link.
There's a link to call and write their representatives in Washington.
And uh,
there it is right there.
So that is,
um,
that's the issue.
And a,
this is a way to,
uh,
to voice your disapproval of this issue.
And there's the handsome Steven Ella,
right,
right man.
Now you could always get my shell,
you know that meat eater dot.
Vh EHS.
Dot.
T but it's important man.
It's like the network sportsman channel has been so good to work with over the
years because they never ever mess with us about content.
We do the kind of show we want,
we put out the kind of message we want.
It's like it's just the,
it's just so nice and they,
and they just allow you to authentic stuff that you think is best.
It's just they've been great.
Great to work with.
And I hate to see him crippled in any way.
What other reasons?
The word out.
I'll put this out on Twitter and Facebook tonight and uh,
hopefully we can make some sort of an impact.
Uh,
in the meantime,
got to check out the mediator podcast cause it's fucking excellent.
Uh,
I've been binge listening this week cause I know Joe Rogan experience.
How dare you.
It's excellent.
It's very good.
And if you're interested in hunting,
it's very good.
And if you're not interested in hunting,
you might get interested in hunting from listening to it,
but it's excellent.
Um,
and then the book,
the book is the complete guide to hunting,
butchering,
and cooking wild game.
It's available as of August,
right?
It's available,
One big game is out now.
Volume two,
you can preorder.
All right.
That's it.
And a,
when are we going hunting again,
man,
we got to figure one out.
Do it.
You got to figure out what you want to go.
Okay,
we'll figure it out.
I want to do pandas.
Bad Panda bears.
I'll joke.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
All right,
well then not that.
See You folks.